and often in film festivals they'll tell
you like the ticket to buy at the film
festival is the short comp compilations
because that's where the really most
exciting film making is
happening what is a short film what is a
short film is a really good question
because a short film can be anything but
I think what defines a short film
obviously is the length it's a short
film and there's actually a few
organizations that do have like a
definite defined length of what how long
a short film should be for example like
if you want to be uh considered for an
Academy Award
the academy says a short film is I
believe the Academy's 40 minutes or less
for for narrative documentary sometimes
has different links for um their films
quite often for film festivals in the
application they'll say specifically how
long the short film can be to qualify as
a short film usually it's like 50
minutes or less although personally I
think if you're making like a 50- minute
long short film that's a too long of a
short film short film should be short in
my
opinion do you know what percentage
actually way past a half hour I mean
isn't generally it's 15 minutes or under
well a lot of people because they see
short films that are longer they think
that's how long a short film should be
so they've seen student films that you
know the university requires the film to
be a certain length because it's a
learning experience right so you want to
do a longer film so you get the full
experience of making something you know
you're not making something on half a
day and it's 30 seconds long or
something like that so when people are
used to seeing these kind of longer
short films they think oh that's what
makes a good short film a short film
should be 20 minutes long or 30 minutes
long or they worry people won't take
them seriously if their film is not that
long but truthfully because I've seen a
ton of films on the festival circuit I
feel like if you're beyond 12 minutes
you're just too long and quite often for
like uh dramatic films 12 minutes is
like a nice sweet spot like aim for 12
minutes or less I'm always a big fan of
or less but if it's a comedy short or a
short you expect to have be on the
internet nobody's going to be watching a
12 minute short on the internet you know
at the internet we have no attention and
we want to be short short short short
short and comedies you know as with
features if you're too long you outstay
you're welcome you should be short fast
and funny has it changed as as different
uh social media platforms have given us
more short content well also when you
say what defines a short film you know
things that people are making for on
social media are shorts right I wouldn't
necessarily call them films per se but
they're short pieces of content so you
know like when tic tac's Tik Tok started
it was extremely short teeny teeny teeny
is what it was supposed to be and there
used to be a service called Vine and
that was like six seconds long um and
that I would consider those shorts not
necessarily films but short pieces of
content so it is amazing how much you
can tell in a short short short short
time period of time but even Tik Tok
realized they had to start giving people
more time you know that it's really hard
to do such to actually do some kind of
Storytelling in a very very very very
like you know one minute or less time
frame having said that I've seen great
short films that are minute and or less
what draws you to the short film genre
I'm kind of unique in the sense that I
started out the first thing I ever
produced was a feature and then I
started producing short films and people
always say don't you want to go back to
features and I love shorts it's like
features features are hard short films
are fun fast and easy to do and that's
where I think the most exciting
storytelling is and often in film
festivals they'll tell you like the
ticket to buy at the film festival is
the short comp compilations because
that's where the really most exciting
film making is happening unique voices
are happening unique things that you can
do with cameras and fun you know off
the- wall things all happen in short
films first because we can it's a format
to experiment in to take chances in to
do crazy things in you don't have have
that same pressure of having to do like
a 90minut storyline with three acts and
characters who have to develop and all
the things that you know you have to
make happen for feature with a short
film you can even take like a small
smallest idea and do it great and well
and crazy and unexpected and surprising
and so that's what I love so much about
short films it's every year there are so
many made and every year there are so
many other just amazing that you've
never seen anything like that before
they're funny they're surprising they're
touching they're moving and so many
feature films I'm sure everybody
watching this has had that experience
that you pay your money to go see in the
theater and you feel very disappointed
afterwards you're like it's the same old
same old or oh I was expecting it to be
so much better often because the trailer
kind of sold you on how great it was
going to be because the trailer has
shown you all the best moments but the
resulting feature is long and not great
where short films rarely
disappoint has there been a a Resurgence
in shorts or short film making has never
really gone away well the thing about
short film making is uh you know it's
always been around right when actually
when when film making started it was
short films it was one reelers right
that those were the silent films that
people could make and the birth of films
was shorts um and then they graduated to
more and more reals that became a full
length feature so short film gting is
always always always been there um and
students make shorts all the time so in
that sense it's always been there as
well but what has made it very very
democra the what has made it easy and
accessible and Universal to everybody is
now that you know we have something in
our pockets that are cameras that we can
shoot films on and that has never been
the case before so every single person
practically has the ability to shoot
something and that's a miracle now
whether you're actually a Storyteller
that's something completely different
but you actually can put your camera up
film something put a title on it put it
out on YouTube put it out on social
media and you've made a short film so in
that sense there's more short films
being made than ever and um we often use
the statistics from the Sundance Film
Festival because they're very uh out
with you know public with their numbers
and every year they say this many short
films have been submitted to the
Sundance Film Festival and it has grown
exponentially when I was making short
films very small amount because people
were still shooting on film and then it
you know we could shoot digitally and
now we can shoot on so many different
formats but so many people are making
short films so last year the people
people that applied to this year's Sund
ends Film Festival last year they were
obviously making their films during the
pandemic but still over 10,000 people
made short films and submitted to
Sundance so you can see that's a lot and
that's of course only people who
submitted to Sundance but that's a lot
of people making short films how many
types of short films are there short
films can incorporate anything so when
you say types it's like what does that
mean exactly does that mean like live
action animation documentary those are
kind of or mixed media um or those are
buckets that you can say and that's kind
of what way um people classify short
films like for example the academy when
they do their short films Awards it is
live action animation documentary but
when you say short films is it mean
something like a narrative short is done
in a traditional short film making way
is it something that is like a parody is
it something that is you know an adapted
uh short story that is turned into a
short there's so many different kinds of
shorts within those buckets and that's
again what I love about short films is
like basically anybody can say they what
theyve made is a short nobody's going to
stop you because there's no like
official board that says this is a short
this is a short you could decide I'm
going to make something I'm deciding
it's a short and here it is it's out in
the world so you know for Sundance
10,000 people submitted short films this
last year for consideration for the film
festival what were those 10,000 short
films how do you define what they were
you know obviously the programmers
watched 10,000 and they could answer
more accurately they saw amongst those
different things so sometimes it is
literally people who have no clue what
they're doing and they just say oh I've
made a short film because I ran you know
I push record on my camera and I push
stopped and that's what it is and they
submit it and again I'm not saying that
is not a short film um but it might not
be something that's worth our while
watching and then there's the definition
of a vlog which could have typically the
length of a short but there is a there's
it's like someone speaking to the camera
as if they're like zooming with you
right so what is that a short film per
se you you know but what if it was with
an actor who was that was written and it
was something that had a definite
beginning middle and end so it wasn't a
legitimate Vlog but it was a story that
was told in the format of a vlog and it
has a title then I would consider that a
short film but a actual real Vlog I
would not consider a short film in the
same way you would say like is a news
broadcast a short film however like I
would used to always say this is Brer
film from the Kennedy
assassination could that be a
documentary short that like everybody
had seen around the world
is that a short I don't know maybe it's
just a news feature what's the
difference between a 2 to four minute
short and a 20 minute short well the
difference between a two-minute short
and 20- minute short obviously is
running time but it doesn't necessarily
mean that a two-minute short isn't as
good as a 20- minute short or that a
20-minute short should be taken more
seriously than a two-minute short
because I've seen amazing films that
were two minutes long and I've seen
amazing films that were 20 minutes long
I've also seen films that are 20 minutes
long that should not have been 20
minutes long and one of of the main
criticism of anyone who deals with short
films professionally like maybe they're
a TV programmer or they're a program for
for a festival is that short films are
too long the problem is many people
write and direct and edit and produce
the short film themselves so they're
like a oneman band and they've done
everything which is great because it's a
terrific learning experience but they're
often not good editors or because they
also wrote it and shot it that they
can't tell what they need to take out or
not and with a short film concise
concise edit down you know we we pay
attention to every single moment in a
short film because every single moment
is important so quite often that 20
minute long film has really only enough
story for 12 minutes per se but the
filmmaker can't see because they're too
close to it and they've touched every
single part of it what can be taken out
to make it shorter so you know I
personally when I see a 20-minute long
film I'm watching it going oh this
should have been shut down this should
have been cut down that's too much
there's there I also have a thing called
uh feature film pacing and that's
because we've grown grown up watching
feature films and television and that's
so naturally that's our pacing when we
watch things we expect them to go in
that space well a film that has 90
minutes or a TV show that has 42 minutes
has a lot of time to set up a lot of
information and do a lot of things where
short film doesn't have all that time
and in short film you should be paying
attention to every single moment so
quite often a 20 minute long film has
feature film pacing where they'll like
spend way too much time at the beginning
with like a long credit opening sequence
that for a feature you have to do
contractually but for a short nobody
wants to watch that we don't need to we
don't want to we want to get right into
the story I used to have a friend that
we'd go to festivals together and he'd
be like every short film starts with
somebody walking somewhere in a short
film no you're already there and then
we'd watch it we' like y sure enough
somebody's walking somewhere no in a
feature sure you can walk somewhere you
can stop at the store you can shat with
friends and then you'll get to where you
want to go but in a short film you are
already there and we're already going
every single s moment csel a short film
so in the similarity of let's say a
novel a Nolla and a short story there's
rules that apply to each each length of
a manuscript exactly so like a a short
film a short story there's a certain
style that goes for a short story and we
know when we're reading it it's only
going to go a certain amount of pages
and we know it's going to have an ending
that's going to come up kind of quickly
so we're interested in where where that
ending is going to come uh and it's very
rare that a short story can be expanded
to being a Nolla or even a like novel
nobody reads the short and goes you know
really have a novel here maybe you
should expand it um sometimes it happens
but it's r that it does so for a short
film it has its own style and it has its
own thing that we're expecting from it
um and then yeah maybe Nolla would be
those 50 minute shorts which usually is
in documentary you know that it's more
like a TV episode that just happens to
be a documentary and we're used to that
too from you know from watching TV
documentaries that are that long it's
totally acceptable to have a 50-minute
dock you know maybe you have a long
story you need to convey but not enough
to make it full 90 minutes and cruel it
would have been cool to cut that story
down to half an hour or 20 minutes it
has to be 50 minutes or 40 minutes I
think documentary is a whole another
kettle of fish but again with short
films anything goes you can do whatever
you want and if you come up with a story
that only works in 10 minutes then do it
in 10 minutes if you come up a story
that you have to take 40 minutes to do
and that truly is as long as it needs to
be then go for it or maybe it really is
a feature and maybe that 10 minutes
you've made is to kind of hook people
into realizing that there's actually a
feature in here um so there's quite a
lot of short films that are that they're
kind of like proof of concept or a
little teaser of what the feature could
be right and this is just a side note
but I think the LA times has now done in
this new short docs that they have on
yes New York Times has did at first and
those were very very popular and then
I've seen the Los seles times is now do
to but you know what anybody who wants
to give credit to short films and show
short films more power to them uh
because you know that's kind of the
hardest thing is to get people to see
your film so if there's some kind of
organization like a film festival or a
imprint like the New York Times op docs
or the LA Times docks that's just so
fabulous they're putting them out there
they're getting a promotion because
truthfully nowadays the easiest thing is
to make a film this is for shorts and
for features the hardest thing is to get
distribution and to get people to watch
your film
what are the main reasons someone should
make a short film here's the great thing
about short film making I truly believe
everybody should make a short film if
you want to I'm Not Gon to force you to
make a short film if you weren't
interested to make a short film but
there's nothing to stop anybody from
making a short film so if you have
something you want to say or make or
maybe you just want to experiment and
try to do something because the
experimental is also a really fabulous
category of short films go for it nobody
ever regrets having made a short film
and one of the reasons is it's not so
financially disabling as making a
Feature Feature you put a lot of moneyy
in a lot of people's expectations and it
really has to deliver short film
shorttime commitment to make hopefully
very very little money that you put into
it so why not go ahead and do it so I
always encourage people to make short
films I think often you'll find out
festivals the festival people will tell
you too like the people who had the most
fun at film festivals are the short
filmmakers because nothing's really
writing on it you know it's not like
there's a lot of investment you're just
there you've made something you're proud
of and you're like Hello World here I am
I'm now a filmmaker and that's the great
thing about shorts too it's that nice
Bridge from I'd love to be a filmmaker
to actually being a filmmaker fastest
way to do that is to make a short film
but having said that I also don't think
you should make it so precious as like I
must have the perfect thing before I can
become a short filmmaker I do think and
this is also what's kind of nice about
film school you can make a lot of small
things to kind of experiment and do
stuff and find your voice that you don't
necessarily need to show the world right
that it could just be something for you
to experiment and to find what you are
as a filmmaker to exercise your film
making muscles it doesn't have to be
shared with the world so quite often I I
teach and a lot of my students want to
immediately put their film out into the
film festival or put it on YouTube and
that's permanent you know that sends the
world you're it's now something in your
IMDb page it's now something that you're
showing people that say this is
represents me as a filmmaker and if it's
not something that really is of quality
yet that it's still just a learning
experience because I always say shorts
are a learning experience for everyone
if it is truly a learning experience you
can just say that was it I made it and I
learned a lot from it but now I'm ready
to do my more uh ready for the world
short film so you know everybody can
make a short film I would always
encourage everyone to make a short film
I don't necessarily encourage everyone
that everything you make is so perfect
that you know your mom's going to love
them all obviously um and your best
friend will love it and the people who
are in it will love it but doesn't
necessarily mean that the world has to
see everything you've made you should be
a little cautious about what you send
out into the world well that's a great
Point how does someone know though
because sometimes we all think
everything we do is amazing or or we
have the flip side of that problem but
yeah that's true some people do have the
flip side but they're super critical and
it's like well how do you know that it's
not great until you actually show it to
people so you know one thing I do like
is doing private screenings where like
you and your friends you can get like
five friends all of whom made something
show it at home people now have
beautiful TVs you know invite people to
your apartment you know make popcorn
have a private screening like a cast and
cruise screening and that's a great way
especially if show more than one film to
see how it plays with people people who
are obviously on your side um but if you
have a bunch of different casting Crews
there are strangers there who you know
aren't related to you and see how it
plays see what people do people do test
screenings of features all the time so
do a test screening of your short and
see what
happens however I will say you know it
used to be in the world of like if you
build it they will come like put it up
on YouTube people will Discover it and
all of a sudden you'll be on Jimmy
Fallon talking about your short film
that made your whole difference there's
so many things going up on YouTube now
there's so many things that are out
there you can't count on like if you
build it they will come it really has to
be um a concentrated effort to get
people to see your film so if you're
worried about it you know do that kind
of test screening if you are if you do
want to send it out into the world then
you know that's what festivals are for
now some people's shorts are not
Festival quality shorts and I will also
say I know so many filmmakers who like
apply to all these festivals and don't
get in don't get in and they're like my
film must really suck it does it's not
getting into anything and then finally
it breaks for the they get into one film
festival and then they get into another
and get into another so you know number
one your film just might not be a
festival kind of film and that's totally
fine but also it may just be that you
know again 10,000 people made short
films that were submitted to Sundance so
don't think that you know because you're
one of the 10,000 and you're not getting
in it's because you personally suck uh
I've been on a lot of short film Journey
juries and you know at festivals and I
always want to tell people that we're
like number like we gave the big prize
to film number a but film number B we
debated forever about and we all really
liked it just didn't get the prize and
you always want to say I wish the
filmmaker knew that you know how much we
Lov their film and talked about their
film and even though they didn't
actually get the prize you know they
should be very very proud of that but
you don't hear that all you hear is film
number A1 and I didn't win anything so
you know you could honestly be film
number B where you've got so much
potential it just didn't didn't happen
for you at that time do you advise
filmmakers to make a short film from
their screenplay such as like filming
sequence from maybe the first page so a
lot of people do that that they have a
screenplay and there's no like they
can't get people to look at their
screenplay that's like the hardest thing
right to break into Hollywood and get
people to look at their screenplay so
people say to them you know well maybe
you should shoot a little bit of the
film and of the screenplay and then
people can see that and see the
potential of what this thing could be so
uh quite often those are like proof of
concept shorts that you take either
little scene or you maybe take one of
the characters from it and film
something different with with that
character just to show the that that
character has a lot of potential and
could be
interesting um the hard part is
sometimes those don't hold up on their
own like that little scene doesn't
really work as a film it works to kind
of show what the screenplay could be but
on the other hand you know you if you
want to make your film for like a 100
million dollars you're not going to be
able to invest that much in a little
teeny bit of a short film so that it
doesn't give you that you know Grandeur
that you would get when they actually
make the feature um so but it's totally
legitimate to make a proof of concept
and then send that little you show
people that bit and they say ah now I
understand what the feature could be you
know a lot of um features are execution
dependent where people just can't see
what it would potentially be so if you
put together little something you're
like now you can see what it could
potentially be so it's worthwhile doing
that it doesn't necessarily mean that's
a festival short it really might be just
truly a proof of concept for that
feature uh script and that's all it is
conversely a lot of people have made
short films that got a lot of attention
then people like you know there's a
feature in there um and then they've
written the feature around the sh film
you know so Whiplash is actually one of
the most famous ones that it was a
feature script first he couldn't get any
attention for it so he took an actual
scene from it and it's on the internet I
think it's on the Blu-ray of the DVD
it's pretty easy to find um of that
scene and um he had uh JK Simmons as the
in music instructor but a different kid
not Miles Teller is the drummer um and
so he shot an actual scene from it and
that's short film also called Whiplash
got into the Sundance Film Festival won
an award and then everybody's like well
he was like well here's the feature
script so that gave him a lot of
momentum by having showing people what
it could be but just to play The Devil's
Advocate for a moment I think wouldn't
there be a little bit of a danger in
just shooting one page because there
wouldn't be an arc to the story it
wasn't just one page it was one scene so
you know yeah exactly you don't you need
to have a beginning middle and end and
that's why sometimes people don't do
some exactly from the script they take
something out of it and carefully
construct it as a short film and those
are more successful because people have
the experience doing it also people have
done like little trailers so recently uh
the uh fresh prince of belir TV show got
remade as just Bel Air and how it
happened was the filmmaker thought oh I
could do this kind of gritty version of
um of the fresh prince of belir now and
he made like a little trailer for that
just for fun because he thought it was
like a a good concept of like let's show
the real Fresh Prince of Bel Air and
based on that they were able to develop
a TV series so it does work quite often
that you can show something and then
people see what it could be and then
bigger pieces
happen actually right now too there's
another there's two films that are out
right now um one film called emergency
feature film on Amazon Prime that was a
short film that did very well in the
festival circuit and then people said to
them this could be a feature and they're
like yes let's make the feature um and
then Marcel the Shell with Shoes On
that's now a feature film too and that
was a short film originally do most
filmmakers realize their short film is a
calling card or almost an online resume
see I agree with you that I think that's
short films no matter what are an online
resume and not necessarily a calling
card of what you want to do for the
future but a calling card of you as a
filmmaker and that's what they should be
this is your chance to do whatever you
want to do that shows your voice like
this is who I am this is what I want to
do so I know filmmakers who for example
have made comedy shorts that got a lot
of success and they were able to get an
agent off of it and they got meetings
with people in Hollywood and everyone
was like here's a comedy we'd love you
to do and they're like well really what
I want to do is drama was like well
everybody got excited because you could
show them your comedy on a similar note
I know a filmmaker who did a short film
with a dog um and it was just happened
to be that there's a dog in the story
but then he got offered all these dog
features and he was like I'm not a dog
filmmaker but that's what people can see
they're like oh he works well with the
dog we happen to have a dog script we're
looking for a dog director
here we go so you have to be a little
careful that knowing you know you if you
wanted to make horror films you should
think about what your future holds so if
you want to make horror films then you
should do a horror short you know you
can do a comedy horror short or
something like that but you should think
about where you want to go if you want
to be a documentary filmmaker I think
doing a narrative short doesn't really
help you in any way if you want to uh
you know make really slick kind of
things in the future you should make
slick thing as your short film but it
also should reflect who you are too so
like for example you know yeah if you're
a comedian or something like that you
shouldn't nobody's expecting you to make
a drama you know heart rendering drama
film and then you know have you say but
what I really uh this is who I really am
it's like well no we always knew you
were a comedian this is weird that you
want to do these dramas so you have to
think about who you
were where you're going and make
something that is true um expression of
you so then is don't necessarily make
something just to get in a festival try
to establish your style and what you
want to do and not just do it for Trends
well people always ask for example the
program as at the Sundance Film Festival
it's like what is a Sundance short is if
you could do like if you tell me it's a
b and c and I do ab and C then I'll get
into Sundance right and they always say
no you know we put together this whole
group of different things to put
together the fil film festival and so
there is no specific this is what we
want so you can't just say like you know
a clown crazy clown film one last year
so if I do crazy clown film then I'll
win this year or that's what they love
they love crazy clown films so I'll
definitely get in if that's what I do
really what people are looking for is
something unique and special and moving
and heartfelt and you know audience
pleasing and um they want to feel like
there's some Talent there and they're
they're going to nurture this talent and
expose this talent to the world so there
isn't like a formula that can that says
this is what will be successful H and
you know some people make a great short
film and then make another short film
and it fails terribly depending on what
you consider failing um you know doesn't
get reactions from people or people
don't think it's as good as their first
film then they make a third film and
people are like it's still not so great
or it's amazing so there's no there's no
rules about what makes a good short film
or what you should make there's no
definition of what's a failure too and
and quite often filmmakers will tell you
they had to make certain things before
they're ready to make their next film so
those little bits of what some people
might consider a failure weren't a
failure at all it was a learning step
for them so that they could get up to
the next step so you know that's the
great thing about short films there's no
there's really no failure it's as long
as you're making stuff and you feel like
you got something out of it and it was
worthwhile and you've developed your
muscles as a filmmaker then you should
consider it a
success can you run down the feature
film pressure that short films kind of
lessen the burden of so what are kind of
some of the problems of a a feature that
a short film either doesn't have or has
a lot less of short feature films are
are a big deal right you're usually
going to shoot at bare minimum like 12
days 18 days 24 days short films I
honestly am a big believer in like a
weekend short film making two days maybe
three days maybe four days but that's it
so in terms of like just in terms of a
production that you have to manage
shooting 24 days versus shooting four
days is a radically different thing also
you know uh quite often smaller crew for
a short film because you're quite often
doing things without needing to have all
that elements that go along with making
a feature happen so you can get away
with less people I mean I know a lot of
people don't do continuity for a short
film whereas for a feature film you
should have a script supervisor for a
short film maybe you don't need it up to
you really um so you know also in terms
of the people who work on the short film
quite often it's your friends it's
friends from film school you don't need
to get a professional cinematographer
you know you're you're you can shoot it
yourself if you want to you sound I
always think sound is super important
for anything for a short film or future
film you should really make sure you
have good sound as good sound is a
feature film would have but so sound is
something don't skip on um so you know
production wise much easier on a short
less to pull together and quite often
you're doing it when you're in school
too so you have the advantages of people
in school School production stuff you
can use the camera can be provided from
school your classmates are there so you
don't have to work so hard to get a crew
you know it's the infrastructure is kind
of there for a short film usually um for
a feature it's a bigger ask to get
people to work you have to pay them you
should do things correctly for a feature
too and that's the other thing I'll say
real quickly for a short film I always
say it's like you could treat it as a
dry run for feature and do everything
properly you know keep the hours the way
you would keep them for a feature use
sag actors do a sag contract and learn
how all that works so that when you make
the feature you're already familiar and
you've already made mistakes you've made
the mistakes on the short film that
doesn't Count versus the feature if you
make a mistake there it could be very
problematic in many ways so short fil is
a really nice way to learn how to do it
properly um and so that when you're
ready to make a feature you're ready to
make a feature and that's quite often
too why people want you to have made a
short first two because you've learned
things so that you're not learning on
the feature you've already you now are a
filmmaker after having made that short
film and you've uh you know shorts are a
learning experience for everybody I
always say so a lot of things will go
wrong on your short but you can salvage
it with a short film with a feature it
could be a lot more
problematic storytelling though too is a
big deal this is a different kind of
Storytelling for a feature film than a
short film so for a short film quite
often people will put in so many
characters and so many storylines it's
like no simplify simplify for the short
film you don't need to do all of that
for a feature you know it's very hard to
do a feature although there've been some
great ones made with like one person one
actor we lead actor of some sort or one
setting short film you can get away with
something like that you can get away
with two people in a room if you need to
you can't do a whole feature two people
in a room well you can but again
questionable whether people really want
to see that so you know also with a
short film and I always try to encourage
us too you can do so many things
uniquely with filming you could actually
still shoot 35 with a short film just to
have the experience of doing it you
could shoot your entire film with a
drone if you wanted to you could uh you
know shoot your entire film with 16
millimeter film there's so many
different ways that you could do it
technically that you couldn't
necessarily do with the feature so why
not experiment with a short film
and try different aspects of things
storytelling too you don't necessarily
have to do act one act two act three you
know again many features have done act
three first but for the short you can
totally you act three first and you know
Skip two and just go back to act one at
the end there's also for shorts we like
a lot of um twists and turns and
surprises and with a feature you know
you can do that but it's still got a lot
of story that has to tell so you can't
do as many crazy things as you can do
with storytelling as you can with a
short how should a filmmaker plan out a
shooting day when you should shoot your
short film is when you're available the
people who are going to help you are
available and the location is available
and sometimes it all falls apart on you
and you can just say well it's a short
film it fell apart we can call it a day
and do it again next weekend you know it
was raining that day for example well
with the feature film you know it's a
problem because you're supposed to be
shooting for seven days you know 10 days
12 days whatever for a short film it's
raining that day sorry we're not
shooting today we're going to have to
start and do it another
day okay so how much planning those
should someone do like let's suppose the
stars are aligned and things are
actually going to go well uh should they
do their own call sheet I mean should
they really you said people should act
as if it's almost a feature and so
there's two schools of doing it you can
do it in a dry run for making a feature
where you really do everything do a call
sheet do um everything that way you
should do it like for a feature so you
have that experience of doing it and I I
personally like that way of doing it
because then you you get the double bang
for your buck you get the experience of
making a short film and you're ready now
to make a feature and everything that
you've learned that you did wrong the
first time around with a short you'll
now know to do right for the feature but
I also am a big fan of like me and my
three pals are going to go make this
thing and so we don't need to plan it
all out I have commissioned a short film
years ago I used to do a DV series and
we commissioned a filmmaker to make a
short film and he literally just had his
friends do it and they they go up on a
bus and everyone's like how'd you get
the rights for the bus he's like we just
went into the bus
um and you know he planned it all out
ahead of time but just he and his
friends did it that day and there you go
it was done um and he didn't get permits
and um you know they just rented a car
and then he told me later it it was
involving animals in Mascot outfits you
know driving a car and he was like later
I found out they had like no vision in
those mascot helmets and they were
driving this car and it was like yeah
that sounds terrible that sounds like a
lwuit waiting to happen but it wasn't it
all worked out fine so you know uh sure
filmers are dumb and we're willing to
try anything and they don't really worry
about it's like yeah let's just get
let's just go on the Bus Let's just
drive the thing he can't see but we're
only going half a block hopefully it'll
be fine um so you know and that's why
people always get hurt on a short film
or something gets broken you should
always prepare for loss and damage on a
short film as well it's a learning
experience for all of us in a similar
way if you're going to do another film
with the somebody in a mascot suit now
you realize the car needs to be up on a
trailer and be professionally trailed
and then they can be driving in because
they're not really driving yeah know
it's interesting where you can kind of
get away from it and we're not
advocating you know being in in major
public spots and obstructing sort of the
the flow of people but I know one place
that I there was like a mailbox on this
one dirt road and I would pass it on my
way to work I was like I really need
this shot whereas Metro no problem that
shot I finally got actually got a woman
from the homeowners association who saw
me blocked my car wanted to know my name
so some sometimes it's very interesting
what you can get away with and what you
can't for some reason she saw me and
then on my way to work after that the
next few days there were new signs up no
filming whoa I don't know what prompted
it but you never know what's going to
actually tip someone tip the scales a
little bit so well that's the
disadvantage of shooting in Los Angeles
because we have so many Productions and
people are so used to it that you know
it's not like you're shooting in your
hometown and I always Advocate shooting
your own Hometown because people want to
help you there and it's not that issue
as if you're shooting in Los Angeles we
shot a short film in a mini mall and it
was the perfect location um and we paid
everybody the it had a laundromat and a
restaurant and we totally redecorated
the restaurant they had to shut down for
the day and we paid for all of that
these were well produced well funded
short films but uh anyway then the owner
of the mini mall showed up and he's like
you have to pay me I it's not the
renters of the mini mall it's the owner
I was like ooh okay lesson learned like
shorts are learning experience for
everyone I didn't realize it was the
actual owner so when I say to you like
you can shoot in your apartment in
reality you should have the landlord's
permission to shoot in the apartment but
you know you should be shooting your
apartment whatever but lesson learned
it's the owners that have to officially
give you permission to and sign the
release for the location
permit how does a filmmaker decide what
kind of short to make you should
definitely make something that you want
to make I always say and this is for
shorts and for features you know when
people say well what makes a good film I
always say there's three things the very
first thing is something you want to
make for shorts and for features you
shouldn't make something you don't want
to make you're going to be the prime
driver of this and you're going to live
with this for the rest of your career so
don't think you know horror films are
very popular so I should make a horror
film it's like no if that's not who you
are or what you want to do this is the
short film as your chance to do what you
want to do so don't sell out because you
think you should do that no do something
you really want to do so the first thing
is make something you really want to
make then the second part is is make
something that other people want to make
so if you can't convince anyone to star
in your short or help you help you know
direct it and or produce it or act in it
or um you know even crew on it if people
aren't so excited to help you on it that
might be your first clue that this is
not something really is ready to be made
at this period of time um or maybe you
don't have enough money to make it I
know a lot of people who written short
scripts and you look at and you're like
well do you have
$20,000 because if you don't have that I
don't think you're going to be able to
make this film again we're so used to
seeing features that do all these
incredible things that we it's hard for
us to realize well yeah that has budgets
of you know millions and millions of
dollars so if you want to do something
that was kind of like that but only two
M two minutes long still you're going to
need a million dollars so you know do
you have a million dollars you got to
scale back and do what you can actually
physically do for a short film so
something you want to make something
others want to make and is makeable and
then lastly this is the part that you
can ignore or not ignore but something
that other people want to see so you
know just because you want to make it
and your friends want to make it it
could be that you know you're not
getting into festivals because it's just
not a film that people really want to
see so um I always say um there's a lot
of people make short films about
Alzheimer's and I'm always like oh
another Alzheimer's short it's a story
that they really felt like they wanted
to tell and there's a lot of older
actors who love to do that film too and
you can get great actors and great drama
in the story and it really could be
moving but we've seen that short over
and over and over again and you know in
a submission of like 20 short films two
of them will be all Arma shorts and
you're just like we've seen it the
audience SE has seen it it's just
overdone so you know there are certain
things that are just overdone it used to
be for while zombie shorts like
everybody was making zombie shorts I
think because the makeup was easy to do
or accessible and again there's inherent
drama in Zombies right and maybe that's
something people really want to do
they're like I want to direct the
walking dead so I'm going to make a
zombie short and you know having said
that there's some zombie shorts that I
absolutely adore and people did crazy
things with it like zombie prom and um
there's a great one called I love you
Sarah Jane so there's some I love is
zombie shorts but there's been a lot of
zombie shorts so you know yours has to
be different so that people don't be
like another Zombie short sure and what
was the feature uh Alzheimer's feature
was it away from her oh wasn't there
Alice was one too there's been a lot
yeah there's been some great features
but yeah I get it for a short it might
be yeah but even now if you try to make
another feature of that people would be
like haven't we seen that a hundred
times already sure sure there's certain
topics that are just you know you could
argue Universal and always of interest
and again your specific version of it
would make it specific and not so
Universal you know everybody has a
different kind of story with it um so in
the same way there's lots of different
ways you can do zombie shorts so not
talking you out of it I'm just saying by
the way there's a lot of that however
again like coming of age aren't there a
million Coming of Age stories and each
one is different and unique so you
should tell your own Coming of Age story
that you really want to tell and quite
often students do because like what
living have they done coming of age just
all the living they've really done so go
ahead and make a Coming of Age story and
I I'm sure it'll be you know very moving
and touching and something you wanted to
make and others wanted to make there
just might be a point where people don't
necessarily want to see it because like
we've seen a lot of coming of a shorts
sure or or about like a family member
but I know there was there's been a few
where there was one about a guy whose
dad was a musician and he kind of gave
it up to raise his kids and there was a
part of him that felt very resentful
about that and it was a great look at
how this guy never really got to connect
with his dad because his dad always felt
like I gave up my art for you and and it
was the way it was done was was I me you
had tears in your eyes I love moving
short you know so as much as I'll try to
talk filmmakers out of something like oh
no don't do it we've done if it's moving
I don't care if I've seen a million of
them before I want to be moved and I
want to be touched and I want to hear a
story that the filmmaker had to tell
despite 100 people telling them don't do
it theyve been too many of them or
whatever if you have something
passionate you want to say and do then
it'll translate onto screen and we'll
see it and be like wow even though we
said we've got a million of them we're
only going to show one we're going to
show yours cuz yours was so fabulous
sure and but then there's a danger and
you could do it oh my Uncle Joe's just
great and everyone's like sure he's a
sweet guy but what's where's the arc
here you know so that there is you know
I get my big pet peeve is endings that
so many people and this what turns what
with sketches a lot too that there just
no ending and with short films we really
are critical about the ending quite
often there's a big terrific twist at
the end that takes you completely just
by surprise and everything you've seen
before you now reevaluate um and those
shorts tend to do great because we're
not expecting that um but no matter what
there has to be a reason that your short
ends at that time and that ending has to
feel satisfying to the viewers so you
know I think that's where a lot of
people fail too is that just Peters out
there's no real ending there's no last
statement or anything like that um it's
just like and it's over maybe because
they ran out of money or because the
ending didn't work and they just kind of
cut back till they felt something they
thought could potentially work but
ending is so important what if someone
can't decide whether to make a short
film a feature film or a TV pilot so TV
Pilots I don't really have much to say
on that front because it's not my
specialty and it's also tricky in this
world I mean I think you could make
something that other people will say oh
that could actually work as a pilot for
or concept for a TV show so it wasn't
like a 22 minute or 42-minute
fullon legitimate pilot you know which
again people are used to expensive uh
stuff on TV so if you have those if you
have those Millions sitting around so
you can make a pilot that looks like a
real pilot go for it but you can do a
part of it or a little segment of it or
a trailer of it to give people an idea
of what it could potentially be but for
a short film or for a feature film um
you know you can you can go ahead and
make it right nobody's going to stop you
from doing it um and I I shouldn't be
just say don't do a TV pilot if you know
how to do it go for it do it again
nobody stops you and that's what's so
fabulous it's like if you want to do it
and you think you know how to do it go
for it totally make it but I always say
too people can tell people can tell from
like watching two minutes of a 20 minute
long film this person is Storyteller
this person knows what they're doing and
they'll often say I don't need to see
the whole film I can see that they know
you know how to work with actors how to
deliver moving moments Etc and that can
show people okay now they're ready to
make that bigger piece so it don't feel
like you have to do the full link thing
to have people appreciate what your
talent is or see that there's talent to
make you take the next step of you know
you don't have to make a lowbudget
feature to get hired to make a feature
there are many people who' have gotten
hired to make a feature based on a short
film or just based on their script by
themsel you know by itself that they can
be a director for it um you know I do
believe in lowbudget film making and
there's a great up no again no one will
stop you and there you can make amazing
things with lowbudget film but I always
think it kind of comes back to money too
you know
no matter how cheap you try to do it
lowbudget filmm for feature that's a lot
of money you know it's even if you're
scraping by with thousands it's like do
you have
thousands you could make a car or you
know could buy a brand new car or you
could make a feature film that and
people aren't used to seeing so cheap
feature films too that's what's also
really difficult they're used to more
expensive films so sometimes they don't
see the value of what you're making when
you've done it so incredibly
cheap I would say you know a short film
that was really short but shows your
talent and shows what you want to do is
more worth of your time and effort and
money and so you know again I don't
think you can make a short film for no
money whatsoever you can make a short
film for $500 you can make a short film
for a couple of thousand dollar quite
often I teach and some of my students
underestimate how much money they have
to put into it especially about post now
when you're a film student you can often
get things to help you with with post
but the difference between something
that you just shot on your iPhone with
no post and something that you do proper
post on
World a difference so you know people
underestimate the money that you need
for post production and then they offer
underestimate the of money you need if
you're going to send your film off on
the festival circuit that's also not
free so all of a sudden it's like let's
say you had $5,000 which I would love to
have $5,000 to spend on my art um you
know I'd rather you make a short film
for $3,000 including all your post and
save $2,000 to send it off on the
festival circuits where you can actually
go and attend these festivals and you
know because they're not going to pay
you to if the festival is not in your
back door they're not going to pay you
to fly you out or put you up but you may
want to do that and then you know you
need money to do that so I would highly
recommend when you're budgeting put
money for post and put Mone money for
festivals if that's something you want
to do what if someone says I'll do my
own post a lot of people do think they
can do their own post because you know
that's the miracle of the the computer
now that so many elements are there and
you can in the same way you can write
your own script or shoot your own script
but I always say like it's a world of
difference if you have somebody shoot it
be a DP for you so why wouldn't you also
have somebody edit for you and be their
give their skills for that and why
wouldn't you have somebody do their
postproduction sound because it's
amazing how much post-production sound
can add to the production value of your
film sound is everything people will
forgive things that don't look that
great but if the sound is good it brings
it up incredibly it makes it so much
more professional um and a lot of people
want to help you you know a lot of post
production places if you approach them
and you're only asking for help on a FIV
minute long short and you have time
you're like whenever if you can do it in
your spare time sometimes you can get
professionals to help you on these
things for not that much money or you
pay like a regular client and if you
have that money you can get top notot I
know a lot of short filmmakers who have
Skywalker sound do their sound it's
doable you know so if you have the money
frankly it's filmmaking if you have the
money a lot of things are possible for
that's true but don't skip on post and
don't skip on
marketing what is the story structure of
a short film because short films can do
anything or say anything and they should
be unexpected and you can do act you
know you're ending at the beginning and
you're beginning at the end there is no
structure so but I do think Simplicity
helps a lot I don't think you should
have a hundred different characters with
a hundred different plots going on and
ab lines it's not like screenwriting
that's when people take do uh short film
screenwriting I'm always kind of like
what could you be talking about because
there aren't the same kind of rules as
there are for features it really depends
on what story you want to tell and then
I just think it's a lot about
simplification and really bringing it
down to simple idea one thing I love
about short films because I'm known for
short films right people will always say
to me oh I saw this really great short
film and then they'll tell me the short
film that they saw so I haven't visually
seen it but I've heard someone tell me
to and I'll be like that sounds like a
great short film and I kind of feel like
I've seen it because they were able to
tell me the whole plot of what it was so
you
know you're short story your short film
should work in that way that people can
tell you what it is but a lot of them
are like just visual one of my favorite
kinds of short films are dialog free
short films where there's absolutely no
dialogue but it is all told you know
it's not like an oldfashioned running
pushing piano up the hill and having a
fall down Laurel and Hardy kind of thing
but just you can tell a story with
visuals the actual old-fashioned visual
film making way um and it's great and so
many and though I also say the short
films with no dialogue translate very
well light very well for different
countries people love films no dialogue
because it's Universal it's you're going
to be a universal story of something
that is told through Cinema it's a very
cinematic way of telling a story but
anyway so yeah nothing you know you can
do anything you want to do and I could
try to talk you out of like don't do
like traditional structure but you can
do traditional structure if that's what
your story needs and is to be told um
endings are really important in short
films Beginnings are really important in
short films and middles are very
important in short films I do think
every scene in your short film should
also you got to look at it and say
beginning and ending you know are we
lingering too long can we get out and do
that before you shoot it because you
know again every moment counts and if
you're going to have a longer shoot if
you have a bunch of stuff in it that
later you're going to cut out in editing
evaluate every scene look at the does it
start as late as it can does it end as
early as it possibly can and then do you
really need it what is the scene
actually about and have we already done
that I hate short films where it just
takes forever to get to the storyline or
they they have a big opening credit
sequence of somebody driving in a car
with beautiful scenery going on and the
credits say you know costumes buy and DP
buy and it's like no for feature films
contractually you have to do that they
have to have full screen credits for
short film there's no thing like that we
have no opening credit sequence people
don't want to sit through that we don't
want to see that start right away with
what your story is and you know you
don't everything is should be what needs
to be nothing Superfluous nothing that
is just there because it may entertains
you um you know you can have a super
chatty film too but just make sure
everything that's in there in chaty
needs to be in there so so I say
probably the biggest thing about the
structure is just make sure it starts
good make sure it ends good make sure
everything in there needs to be in there
has to be in there and as tight as
possible um and that you're happy with
it it sounds like like you said earlier
if someone's walking to go somewhere
have them be already there exactly and
then for the end in uh don't have it
abrupt have some type of a payoff you
know sometimes an Abrupt ending is fine
too but they have it you know work in
some way okay the other thing I should
say too is another huge pet peeve is too
long of credits because on the festival
World your short film will qu quite
often be put in a program of short films
so the audience watches one short film
has to sit through like two minutes of
credits and then now they're ready to
see the other short film and running
time really counts for short films so if
your film is like a 7even minute short
film but 2 minutes of that are credits
no no no no no no fast fast fast fast
for those credits you know shove them up
all on the screen sometimes people
Kickstarter uh or one of those kind of
things and they promise credits on the
screen make them almost
unreadable and have them go there if
you're putting your film online you can
have long credits at the end because
nobody's sticking around for that either
as soon as they see the film is over
they just stop watching it nobody in
features nobody wants to see credits
nobody wants to see credits but don't
have long credits on your film and have
that be part of your running time that
hamper you for uh you know because again
running time counts sure I mean
theoretically you could always have a
website that has that mentions the
backers but I realize it's not the same
as as being in credits but and you know
there isn't necessarily one version of
your film maybe you have the festival
version of your film that doesn't have
those long credits in it and then you
have the web version that does have all
those long credits in it so you know
there are ways to deal with it in that
way too how many different story
structures are there for short
films short films can be anything so
there could be as many different story
structures as you want it to be um but I
don't think there's like an a plot and a
b plot and a c plot like you would have
in like a TV show or something like that
you really just want to have the a plot
you know there might be a little teeny
bit of a runner but doubtful in that way
um and you know that's the thing about
short films it's not the same you know
we don't have like there's going to be a
gangster uh film so these are the rules
for a gangster film um there there is
this is my personal opinion um some
people might feel that there should be
more structure in that way but I say
anything goes whatever you want to do do
can a short film be a series of images
without a protagonist and no structure
so what do you how do you define what a
short film is and you know there's um
experimental shorts that are very famous
and are very um interesting to watch but
there's no storyline whatsoever it's
just images that are happening and
that's fine again no who's to Define
what a short film is and if you say your
film is experimental and that's what you
want to do with it then go for it if
that's what your vision is um and you
know sometimes people love that because
it's like okay we're going to program
this one film that is like a Tarantino
wannabe kind of film and we're going to
program this one short film that's like
a horror film and then we need to do
something different we can't do another
horror film or another Coming of Age so
let's put in the weird you know artsy
thing that uh just Delights us you know
there's also like dance films where
people just film a dance performance or
music videos there's a lot of music
videos that people consider a short film
or you know who's to say if is it just a
music video or is it cinematic enough to
make who besides these things there's
again there's no short film board that
says you are a short You Are music video
you are a commercial you are just drek I
have no idea what you are you as the
filmmaker get to find what it is so if
if you're not a narrative Storyteller
and you just want to make these
beautiful things then that's fabulous
now that's not the person that's going
to be hired to direct The Next Star Wars
film you know and so if that's your goal
you should make something that makes you
more obviously the the person who's
going to direct The Next Star Wars film
um but you that may be that shows you
have such a unique artistic point of
view and people think this person might
be really interesting to make a
different kind of Spider-Man film or
something like that they have such a
unique um eye and thinking and you know
if that's who you are then be who you
are in your short film short film format
just do it so something that doesn't
really have much of a storyline that
might be more geared toward let's say a
contemporary Art Museum there are Museum
pieces but I have also have seen Museum
pieces play in film festivals so um you
know in example of a museum piece the
museum decides you know is this
something that is worthy of being in our
Halls now they also may be completely
wrong too and they're like just seems
like a bunch of drips on canvas who's
this Jackson poock after all you know
who's to say who's right or wrong and
because short filmmakers um you know on
the front lines of doing something
unique and different people might not
understand their film right away and
then in five years time you look back
and you're like oh you know look at this
crazy thing Christopher Nolan is doing
five years ago I saw a short film that
just did that exactly you know we
sometimes are too ahead of the curve and
are doing really special and unique
stuff that is not what people are used
to and that's great too we don't want to
see the same old same old we want to see
something really different and unique
right just to go back and watch Cindy
Sherman like old old videos online from
the yeah and it's like wow this is B
this was ahead of its time this is so
cool isn't that so neat and so like it
short films too they don't really age
that much really terrific short films I
mock like the Lauren Hardy short films
the one reers but people still go back
and look at those and love those and
think they're fabulous if you go back
and watch the Oscar winners for
animation from years ago whoa these
things are amazing and still seem really
special and unique nowadays um and same
thing for live action there's some
liveaction short films that just blow
you it's also really fun to go back and
see like the short films of filmmakers
like Christopher Nolan or whatever ever
and go back and see his short film and
you say oh so George Lucas when he was
at USC did a lot of short
films and some of them are incredibly
boring but still you see what that what
he was interested in and there was all
these sound things you could tell he was
very interested in sound and um and we
can see them now because USC owns those
films and shows those films but so it's
super interesting to see famous
filmmakers now what they were doing in
shs and you can see you know oh I see
their voice in it and that's those are
special filmakers obviously um but yeah
that's why it's really worthwhile going
back and seeing their short
films should you start a short film by
writing a log line I like writing a log
line first to say what in the world is
your short film and even if you don't
think you're going to have it written
down when you talk to people about
having them being part of your film
they're going to say what's your film
about right so you should have a log
line that can tell people what your film
is and if you write it ahead of time and
have it ready to spew and say easily
then that is really a good thing um but
ultimately you're going to have tell
people what your film's about whatsoever
when you finish your film and if you
want to put it online or send it out in
the festival circuit you have to write a
long line that gets sent with that film
and that log line they print for btim so
one of the short films I produced uh was
a film called I'm on fire and it's about
a guy who's on fire we had special
effects to put him on fire so the
filmmaker wrote The Log line and we're
like what in the hell is the log line
going to be for this because um you know
before he comes out in theory you don't
know he's going to be on fire and then
he's on fire um so the filmmaker came up
the long line with a very short film
about a man on
fire pretty much said what it was and it
it was like two minutes long it's a very
short film about a mount on fire so to
this day I can easily quote that log
line because it is that's what the film
is about so um but yeah your log line is
going to follow that film on IMDb
everywhere in the world so you want to
make sure you write it well but also you
don't want to write it so obscurely that
people are like I have no idea you know
because I'm on fire could be a
manifestation of Love told in a unique
way and everyone's be it's that film
about the Man on Fire you know it's like
it that's what it is the title is that
speaking of blog lines titles are also
super important for short films and I
love a unique title because um again
marketing is going to be something you
need to think about and so uh you know
are you going to hashtag it are going to
be a way that people can find it but
there's so many short films that just
have a generic short title that means
nothing and you can't you know there's a
hundred of those films and uh know uh
trying to think of a oh well I have a
friend that did a film called Pig and
that that's a good title and you know
there's not that many films called Pig
so we can find it easily in that way um
but if you do a long title you can
totally do a long title too I always
tell people a short film it's never
going to be on Marquee somewhere so you
can do a super long title if you want
although people will always kind of
shorten it when they tell you what the
version of it is um but I love a unique
title I think that also shows your
creativity and the specialness of the
film it makes people interested um we
also produced a short film called 78 um
and it was about a kid on a manhole
cover jumping up and down and up and
down he keeps on saying 78 78 78 and so
um the film was called 78 and people
would say to us on the festival circuit
they'd see the filmmaker having watched
the film before they're like 78 78 78
it's like how nice look at they're
quoting the title and they remember that
from the film and there you go so you
know yeah if your film is about a man on
fire I'm on fire is not a bad title for
it and uh people kind of know what it so
writing a good log line totally counts
and you should spend time into it it's
also if you write a really complicated
log line that it's hard to follow or
it's too obscure you can write it and
they'll publicize it but nobody's gonna
call it that Thunder Road is a short
film that was it's a terrific show film
people love Thunder Road interesting
enough also BR Springsteen title as as
I'm on fire but anyway um oh yeah that's
true yeah uh Thunder Road when I looked
at his official log line um for it's
about a a cop who's um um giving a
eulogy to about his dead mother um so
that's my log line for it his log line
is it is um officer Arno loves his
mother okay okay it doesn't mention
funeral or eulogy which is a big part of
that short film but that's the logline
that he wrote for it but when most
people say about they're like it's that
one about the cop giving the eulogy
about the mom so your film boils down to
what the ense essence is no matter how
much you try to dress it up and do
different things with it pig is is that
Nicholas Cage's movie Pig no pig is pig
is a terrific film um it's a it's a
genre of urban myths so here I'll tell
you the story of pig often when people
sell stories um so it's a woman in a
Mercedes driving down a uh and she's
super fancy and she's driving down this
windy road and coming up from the
opposite direction no she's coming up
and he's going down um coming down from
the opposite direction is a really gross
guy in a vesa and he's picking his nose
and he's totally he's like a pig right
and so when she passes him she yells out
at the window at him pig when we've seen
him doing specifically gross things and
then um we we don't see it but we hear a
crash and the um move head Falls over
and a pig crosses the road so she was
warning him that there was going to be a
pig that he do it's terrific and people
laugh and laugh and laugh when they it's
online too you can see it online they
laugh and laugh and laugh when just not
expecting to see an actual real pig and
she and so the twist was she wasn't
calling him a pig she was warning him
that there was a pig at the end of the
road that's fascinating so there's a
payoff a great payoff and we don't see
her get do we see her getting into her
car or she just already in already
driving okay great so we've we've kind
of cut to the chase in that part exactly
and then I guess do you they call it
muddy middles where we just kind of like
don't have enough that's clearcut in the
middle does that happen with short films
it does you know beginning is so
important ending is so important so then
we're like well what about the middle
the middle is so important too isn't
that terrible at every single part
counts but yeah the middle is really
tricky and sometimes people put too much
in the middle and we've kind of lost the
thread of what's going on um or they
don't put enough in the middle and it's
kind of like you had a great beginning
and a great end but we don't really
there was no middle to make it really
work so the middle is where people fall
apart too Beginnings middles and ends
all important does a short film have to
have a hook feature films and short
films benefit from having a hook and fil
filmmakers hate to hear that they're
like I don't want to do something crass
and commercial and something that has a
hook but hook just means is there's
something we know what it is and the
hook sometimes can be genre um but it's
so much easier if there is some kind of
um quick way that we can say what this
piece is about without destroying what
it is you know obviously you don't want
to give it all away with and that's
where log lines are tricky if the hook
is something that is given away you have
to craft around um so that people don't
know what that twist is going to be um
but it really does help to have a hook
and uh it also shows you have kind of a
um a good storytelling sense and people
like that and so they're like this
person knows how to deliver something
that really hooks the audience and um is
commercially kind of in that sense it's
not in my world it's not a negative
thing I'm coming from someone who's from
Hollywood so you know maybe the NYU
filmmakers and the Columbia filmmakers
are like hook no don't even talk about
the world hook um but you know to me
hook is not a negative thing it really
is um it gives you a hook for it so we
made a short film called I'm on fire it
was about a guy on fire that's the hook
right now there's a story that happens
there and I'm not telling you about that
story but I say to you it's a film about
a guy on fire would you like to see a
short film about a guy on fire hopefully
people say yes yeah I'm interested to
see what happens then what happens is
what's going to I've hooked you in to
wanting you to make you want to see it
but what why you would like it and tell
other people about it is because there's
a story that you like in it well with
pig what was what's the hook um the hook
is that you think that it's going to be
um uh that he's a pig and the trans
switch is that oh no there's an actual
Pig at the end I see okay right right so
the the hook is like sort of diverting
the audience's attention in a sense so
you actually though I'll tell you the
hook on that is kind of like it's an
urban myth or it's a joke so you know
she's uh dramatized something that is a
uran myth I see okay so typical sort of
Hollywood and and disdain and then you
find out oh no there's an actual animal
that's Crossing okay right well but
Thunder Road is a terrific short film
and it's about a guy who's doing a
eulogy for his mom that's the the hook I
guess would be that he's doing ulil for
his mom the actual not the on the short
film for people but he actually starts
singing along to the song Thunder Road
and so it's very um heartfelt and yet
tricky and weird and uh um it's a
delightful short film but so you know is
the hook that it's a eulogy is the hook
that he actually does a dance and sings
along to to the song Thunder
Road there's two hooks maybe it also is
a One-Shot film too so is that the hook
that we've done a one shot film and and
with short films you can do these really
weird things too like the hook is that
it's all shot with security cameras you
know or it's all shot with a drone or
the hook could be we shot this in IMAX
format um so sometimes it can be the
format it can also be like um the hook
is a vlog that is being dramatized
that's the hook for it sometimes it's
the storyline that it is um also a
format I love is mockumentary and so the
hook there is that we're kind of
thinking faking you out to thinking it's
like a real documentary but it's really
a mockumentary um there there's so many
terrific hooks with short films
primarily because they have to be about
something so um there's a terrific
documentary I love that was part of the
New York op docs called pickle and so
pickle is the world's worst title right
pickle is it going to be about a pickle
maker whatever turns out pickle is the
name of a fish and it's about this
couple that have all these uh pets that
have something wrong with them and I
can't remember what was wrong with
pickle but maybe he couldn't swim or
something like that um so it's a very
very Charming dock about this couple
that have pets that have all these
problems so um that's kind of the hook
of what the film is but it's so touching
and and so um moving and uh but yeah
pickle is a terrible name for it how
much conflict do you need for a short
film conflict and drama is everything in
storytelling right so I think you have
to have it in a short film as well and
by conflict I think it just means um
tension right so you could have one
person being in the entire film but as
long as there's some kind of tension in
what the storytelling or the situation
is you don't have to have two people you
know battling or something like that
when we mean conflict I think it really
just means tension or tight storytelling
um and that's what moves things along so
I think for feature films boy conflict
is essential for everything for a short
film you can Define What conflict means
to you but but we uh we want it tight
and so sometimes you know why a film's
20 minutes long and there's just you
feel like there's nothing going on let's
tighten it and find where the conflict
is in it right let's just go for the
parts that are dramatic and storytelling
and leave out the stuff that seems to be
um extraneous and just character um but
it gives them character it's like we
don't have time for character in this we
got go for what what's the conflict here
what's going on here how much do
antagonists factor to short films so for
a feature film it's like the protagonist
and the an an Agonist for a short it's
great if you can do a protagonist and
antagonist but there's no reason that
you absolutely have to do that that it
could be that's might not be the story
that you're telling uh it could I've
seen a lot of great short films that
have one person is the story so you know
where's your antagonist and there the
antagonist could be something like time
you know or it doesn't have to be a
person per se that is um battling the
protagonist the protagonist has
something that they're working through
whatever so it's not like features that
we need to have you know the protagonist
and the Ant and they have their low
point and their High Point and then the
antagonist learns at the end and the
protagonist learns and no for a short
film you really don't need to do that
but I think it's more interesting if
there is something that your hero is
dealing with do main characters in short
films have goals so in a feature film
yeah you definitely want to have a goal
you know that's always like what's their
uh want and their need and what are they
trying to do for short films I do think
quite often to follow along you kind of
assume that you're going to this person
doesn't even need to be a person right
it could be a dog or something like that
is your lead character but your lead
character is trying to do something or
something is happening to that person uh
and then we'll feel satisfied at the end
when it is complete but it isn't like
the the um you know the myth tell Joseph
Campbell's myths or something like that
with a short film you know your short
film could be two minutes long it's
pretty hard to do seven stages of the
hero's journey or whatever in two
minutes long and and that should be a
feature you know like if you're trying
to do that that maybe moving on to the
Future Part of it for this one let's
just do the training sequence or
something like that we so uh you know I
think every character it's great to have
some sort of goal um it might not be as
complex of a goal or as deep as a goal
it could be totally just as little as
much as like trying to figure out what's
going on here or whatever how much
backstory should you write into the film
I think as much as you as the writer of
a film um you should put all your effort
into as many ways as you can right and
so and actors want to know about all
this backstory so nobody's going to stop
you from doing all of that um but you
don't necessarily need to put it into
what we actually see on screen it could
be all this information that helps that
character be um unique when we see them
on screen so you know you don't you
could do backstory like he loves bowling
so when I'm going to dress him I'm GNA
have him dress in a bowling shirt but I
don't need to see him in the bowling
alley because this is about a story
about you know when he murdered his
mother or whatever um so you know you
want to uh it's great to have all that
backstory stuff in it but unlike a
feature we don't have to see a lot of it
actually manifesting on the screen it
could just be to make them you know and
that's what makes the character special
and unique right it's not just another
killer it's a killer who loves bowling
so that sets yours up from different one
of like if hey do you want to see this
film about a killer who is just wearing
a suit and looks like a quint Tarantino
ripoff or do you want to see one who's a
bowling guy and who wearing a bowling
shirt it's like I'd rather watch the
bowling shirt guy that seems different I
haven't seen that before and maybe
bowling ball will come in and play later
on or maybe it won't maybe it'll just be
a shirt he's wearing right right and
maybe he has like this bowling bag and
you think it's his shoes and he's
keeping them meticulous but it's really
whatever it is he's hiding and so yeah
we've just made a short film let's let's
make it let's do it let's do it but
little tells so you're saying we don't
necessarily go into a long backstory of
course because we don't have time but
there'll be little things that'll
signify they could make it more Rich you
know and that's what we want too we want
things that are special and unique and
have depth to it and that's why I do
think when you go back to see older
short films the ones that stand out have
all those layers and have all this
unique elements to it and are
interesting um and are not just generic
you know we're crossing off these points
to make this happen in seven minutes
look we did it okay good congratulations
you did and that's hard I don't mean to
dismiss that it is hard to make a good
story that works in seven minutes but
you know we're not necessarily going to
stand up and give you a round of
applause just because you did
it 10,000 people submitted short films
to the Sundance Film Festival last year
10,000 people did it it's not so much
anymore like you get a ribbon because
you did it um a lot of people are making
short films so you want to make
something that's so special and unique
and it's worth your time and worth your
effort and worth your money and worth
everybody else's effort of putting all
this time into it so put as much as you
can also you know sometimes you're not
ready to shoot yet so now why not wait
while you're waiting for to get enough
money to shoot or get the right people
to shoot spend that time doing back
stories and developing things more and
you know figuring out to make a set more
unique and you know put it all in there
put everything you want to do in there
but just don't waste time on it and
storytelling time sure and you had
mentioned uh music videos previously do
you think that storytelling currently
with music videos has gotten better or
worse well for a long time music videos
were almost stories all the time right
that they would either build something
into it and then have the music video be
just a little part of it and continue on
um but like Beyonce she does music
stories that uh and they've shown her
stuff in film festivals um and quite
often there's a beginning middle and end
in the story that she's doing and quite
often um her music videos are in heavily
influenced by other films that exist so
she's taken and um you know she and her
director she doesn't direct them all um
you know synthesize all these elements
that her influence and put out visual
albums and visual storytelling um and uh
I used to program a short films by women
uh at the American Cinema Tech and we
would always like to include a music
video because that's another way that
directors direct through music videos
and there were it was very often very
easy to find a music video that actually
had narrative storytelling in it
sometimes they weren't like lipsyncing
along to the music the music was kind of
in the background um but you know there
are very expensive music videos that are
made that are literally short films and
and more power to them it makes them
interesting and not you know your
standard performance somebody's just
standing on a stage and we've captured
it once you finish the short screenplay
what are the first steps in making the
movie so here's the thing I'm actually a
believer of don't do the screenplay
first I think you need to think about
what you want to tell and then can you
tell it because if you're actually
making this thing and financing it
yourself it's not like a feature where
you're writing the whole script and then
you're going around to people and trying
to get funding for a short film more
realistically it's either going to be
like you're shooting it in class because
you have to or you're funding it
yourself to get it made so I I I don't
think it's worthwhile writing a script
that you can actually get made for
example a filmmaker that I produced his
first short film his second short film
he had this great idea that had um big
water effect happening it's like who's
who can afford that who knows anyone who
could do the water effect and just the
film has never been made because just
couldn't do it that way so you can write
it but you know if you're not thinking
like I'm actually making this then you
could write something that you just
never afford to do you could do it as an
exercise but so I think it's more
important to think about okay what do
you want to make and how can you make it
what do you have access to that could
work well for a short film and that's
why a lot of short films and low budget
features like shot in homes because
everyone is like well I have my own home
I can shoot in my own home um and that's
true you totally can but you also have
like your car and you also have uh you
know uh you could go shoot in your
office building or you could go shoot at
the park or you could go shoot you know
your friend has a pool why not set
something in the pool so I think it's
important to kind of think first about I
call it organic film making what do you
have access to um when I teach lowbudget
filmmaking I can't tell you often people
have hospitals in their script it's like
how you going to get a hospital you know
hospitals don't be like sure just show
up we'll let you shoot here so if you
wrote an entire short film that was set
in the hospital only do that if you have
access to either you can pay for a
hospital set or you have access to a
hospital in some way I think it's more
important to think about well what do I
actually have access What story do I
want to tell what do I actually have
access to and can I write something for
that so then it's less money because you
already have access to all of that and
it's more unique you know it's like
think about it that way how many short
films do we see that are based in pools
not that many but if you have an access
to a pool you can come up with something
really unique that is set in that pool
that would make a really interesting
short film so think about that first
before you write it but like you know
you should if you're a horror filmmaker
don't do the I we'll do a sunny story
about somebody in a pool and a diving
contest or something like that no you
should do a Horror Story set in a pool
but won't that be unique because how
many horror stories are set in a pool so
think about what you actually have
access to if you're you have to say to
yourself I'm actually going to make this
thing so I'm actually going to make it
I'm going to probably have to fund it
myself how what how can I do it as cheap
as possible and still have it look great
and the answer is use things that you
can actually get for free so your uncle
owns a dry cleaner fabulous how many dry
cleaner shorts do we know very few let's
figure out something that you can tell
the story that means something to you in
a dry cleaners thing and it'll be horror
film and a dry cleaners I would love to
see that I think it would be really
special and unique so don't just write
it to write it write it in the sense of
I'm going to make this so can I actually
make it and if you can't make it then
you have to kind of put it aside in the
drawer until you're at the point that
you know the right people that can um do
all these special effects that you hope
to do I also think that's also why you
want to think about what your background
is too like you know if you are for
example a a a stunt man and you want to
move into being a director stunt person
and you want to move into being a
director well you have a lot of access
in The Stunt World and people are going
to expect you to do something kind of
stunty so use all of that and that's the
kind of short film that you should make
and
write now that comes the story part and
that's not so easy but at least you have
that Arena of like I'm a stunt person
people are going to expect stunt people
thing I want to direct things that are
stunt heavy I know four different stunt
people I know would be great in this I
know this location that they'll let me
use for free okay now what kind of story
can I create in this and sometimes
you're not the right writer for it maybe
maybe you're like I'm a stunt man I'm
not a writer ah but I've met you know or
maybe you'd have to take a class take a
class with writing so you can meet
writers or you know find somebody who
will write it for you you don't have to
absolutely do everything
yourself you can do everything yourself
and sometimes it's cheaper if you do
everything yourself but um you know work
to your strengths and figure out what
you can do but go in the E theore of I'm
going to make it because there's no
point in having like a whole drawer of
short film scripts nobody's going to
there are a few contests for short film
scripts um so if you want to do that I
say again more power to you and those
maybe you're writing more for people to
read them and to give you Awards and
know that they're not necessarily going
to give the award to the horror story
set in the laundromat or the dry cleaner
but um don't write it just to write it
write it because you're going to
actually make it sure so it sounds like
sit down decide what do I have access to
what's actually in my wheelhouse what
can I do and then once you know okay I
have this dry cleaner you know it's my
uncle's dry cleaner uh store whatever I
know that he'll let me on the day that
they you know shut down they closed on
Mondays Mondays three Mondays if I need
to right right they they know that's
their slow day so they and and then you
know we have this like let say a serial
killer that leaves a letter in a a
jacket or something and and there you go
and then and so then the the young dry
clean worker tries to figure out who it
belongs to anyway but but no another
film we're going to go that's a great
thing there's so many ideas out there
and then you just have to say is this
what I really want to put my time and
effort into making sure and then that's
what when you start the script that's
what I believe that's what you should
start the script and then when you write
the script it doesn't mean like it's
coming out of my computer I'm ready to
shoot then you really have to look at is
this a strong beginning is this a strong
ending is every scene start and end at
the right time you really want to be
very critical on the script stage
because you're going to actually make
this it's not just to be read by people
and say you're a very talented writer
we're not going to hire you but we see
that there's Talent here and we're going
to you know U get you an agent or
something like that is nobody wants to
read a short script you know it is
literally a document to be made so you
know be tight and do all your criticism
of what works and what doesn't work
before you go shoot it because there's
nothing worse than you know coming away
with a long you thought it was going to
be I always tell people like if your
script is 12 pages long it's not going
to be 12 minute short it's going to be a
15 minute short you know that rule of
one page one minute doesn't it's not
concrete of always going to turn out
that way so if you and quite often short
films are more leisurely paced than they
should be so if you write an eight page
script that's more like likely going to
end up being a 10 to 12 page film it
just expands beyond what was actually on
the page oh that's great I didn't
actually think about that so so then
less more yeah less is more plus you're
going to have credits at the end etc etc
so don't you know I'm going to make a
12-minute film so 12-page script here we
go no no no okay so also you don't want
to spend all that money for it like why
shoot the 12 scenes you know him part
him driving up to the dry cleaner
putting money in the meter I was like
that was a day that we spent outside
doing all that turns out we don't need
any of that the story starts inside when
the person walks in the door right so if
let's say it's the it's the replacement
and he's coming in to somebody's day off
and just have him already in the dry
cleaner don't don't show him begrudging
and having to drink coffee and psych
himself up to go there just have him
there he sees an old jacket he feels
around oh there's a letter in there okay
great now we've got a story okay exactly
perfect what if you don't have a budget
what if you can't pay anyone so here's
the thing you know for a short film I
always say nobody's making any money off
of this it's totally a labor of love and
everyone who's going to work on it wants
you to succeed wants the film to succeed
wants it to be as great as it is and
people love to help out so I often say
for short film don't pay anybody you
know if you're only asking for one day
or two days on the weekend people want
to help you out they're not expecting
cash however in a proper production you
should be paying people at least minimum
wage
you are employing these people I always
say people always get hurt on a short
film it's really crew wise you know um
you know and if you're doing sag you
have to have insurance with the actress
too there's a lot of and if you're
trying to do this to learn how to do
film making in a proper way then you
should do it the proper way pay
everybody do the eight hour day 10 hour
day 12 hour day do overtime etc etc do
all the paperwork the way you would do
paperwork for Productions and you're
learning how to do it but I also so am a
big fan of you know you and your four
friends are going to go do this on the
sly um and you know you're not paying
anybody anything but you should feed
them well that's always the rules like
you know so you can't do it for like no
money but you know get your mom to cater
it or something like that um and if it's
your friends that are working with you
they're not they want to help you they
want to do a good job and if you're
students then everyone's kind of under
the student umbrella that way too so you
know but you have to be true to what
your film is if you have no money then
don't write the hospital story that you
don't have access to a hospital unless
you can rent a hospital set that's truly
when you have to set it that if you have
truly no money be creative think of
other ways that you can do it think of
what you um can shoot um and you know
often for short film too like you can
steal a lot of shots too these are not
going to be commercially exhibited more
often than not so you know steal things
not like literally steal things in your
pocket but do shots that you don't have
permission to do shots with that can
give a lot of production value and make
it unique special and you know for a
short film too there's no uh saying that
you can't shoot shoot it for you know 1
hour here 1 hour there two hours here U
there's no rule that has to be shot in a
traditional film making way of we're
bringing all these people together for a
limited period of time so um you know
again shoot on your iPhone that you
already own it you already um you can
edit on your iPhone you can do
everything in that way too so shoot I'd
rather you do something great with what
you can afford to do than try to do
something great with not enough money
and it falls flat because you always
think well I could redo it when I have
money it's like no it's been made that's
what it is you're never going to go back
and be like oh now I have thousands of
dollars and I can redo it but I will
also say for a lot of my students they
think like oh I only have $22,000 I'm
going to make a short film and it's like
yes you you totally can again I know
people who've made short films for $500
for $100 you can totally do it for no
money but money does start creeping in
and you know I'd rather you have $4,000
to do a really great short film than
$2,000 to do a half-ass short film what
are the top five mistakes you see people
make with short films well there's a lot
of things that are kind of clichey like
uh one of the cliches that people always
talk about is the short film or any film
really that starts with the alarm clock
going off and somebody hits their hand
on it and that's how you start the the
film and the day of the character and it
makes sense it's the official start but
it's a very clichey kind of thing that
we've seen uh that so there's like
actual scenes that are kind of clichey
that were like oh no not doing that used
to be like vomiting too that there was
everybody had vomiting in their films
and it was a little too cliche is and
you can do it cheap too so it isn't like
you know we can't afford to do vomiting
just as good as the feature films um but
it is kind of cliche and people don't
want to see it anymore uh the biggest
mistakes that specifically for shorts
are too long the short is too long I
always say that the short is too long um
quite often music people will put in a
short film music that they don't own um
because they you know you can get away
with anything with a short film
um but legitimately you should not have
music in it that you don't own the
rights to so you know it feels so much
better when you put in this Beatle song
you know all of a sudden the production
value seems to go up and it's just
exactly what you wanted and it's a short
you're telling me with my short I should
do exactly what I want so why can't I
put the Beatles song in um but if you
try to put that up on YouTube that
YouTube will immediately their little uh
you know uh algorithms or whatever know
that you have that song in it and you
don't have mission for it and then film
festivals you're supposed to sign
something saying I have the rights for
everything in my short that I am sending
in so you know in theory again they'll
know you didn't you didn't pay for a
Beatles song that was shot in your
apartment for five cents how did that
come to be um and then you know if if in
some miracle uh you know somebody wants
to do something with your film that
involves money later on like they want
to show on an airplane there's very few
opportunities for short films to make
money but if you were lucky enough that
it does there's a film called Thunder
Road it's famous example of it that he
uses the song Thunder Road in it they
play The Brew strings Thunder Road he is
singing along to it there's no way
you're going to cut around Thunder Road
and there's no way you can later
substitute in another song when there's
interest in it so he uh did it as a um
you know like kind of like a calling
card for his talent this short film and
he sent it into Sundance just for the
hell of it and got into Sundance where
he didn't have the rights to it um and
then he won Sundance for the short film
and he didn't have the rights to it and
so people wanted to do all the stuff
with it and he didn't have the rights to
the song Thunder Road so he and everyone
always says don't do this um he wrote an
open letter to Bruce Springstein you
know and so they made a private deal to
allow him to so Thunder Road is on Vimeo
no charge so he's not making money off
of it and we can all see it and but he
did still have to pay spring scen some
money for it so don't put money you
don't own in and don't have people sing
especially the songs you don't have
rights to um and then you know if you do
sag Screen Actor skilled actors there
rules about how that has to be done so a
lot of people make that mistake of they
um they don't think about that they're
going to have sack actors and they
realize they want it and then they're
too late in doing their paperwork for
sag or they don't realize what it means
to have sag actors because there's a lot
of rules about that so that's a mistake
people often make with their short film
not understanding what it means to have
sag actors um and then uh a lot of times
people um have bad acting in their short
films they don't have access to Great
actors um and they think it'll be fine
and then the acting is just terrible the
two things that ruin short films and
lowbudget features but actually all
features bad acting and bad sound so
don't have bad acting uh and then um
don't have bad sound pay to have really
good sound and put a little money in
post- production for sound too it'll
make the world the difference so was
that five I'm not sure if I hit five but
close enough well and then we can always
add in the bonus one which we've talked
about throughout the
walking no I make GL of it but it's
actually it's a great Point yeah have
the person already there you know
exactly start as late as possible and
have them actually there what do you
think about monologues and short films
well I think it can totally be great as
a short film as a monologue is there um
uh is there a reason that you are doing
that and does that monologue have a
beginning middle and end and what are
you showing are we just having somebody
talk or is there some other visuals
happening beyond the monologue um there
is a short film that showed at Sundance
I for indiewire I used to pick like the
best short films at Sundance um so was
always a delight to get to see all the
films that were playing and then pick
which ones were interesting and
different so there was one called I
think it's called Dear Mr Shakespeare
that was a monologue but he had all this
other activity going on beyond the
monologue it's something close to Dear
Mr Shakespeare and that's a fabulous
example of a monologue kind of film
Thunder Road I don't want to keep on
harping about Thunder Road but Thunder
Road is eulogy so I think that's like
basically a monologue um and that's a
super interesting film as well so there
you go already gave you two examples of
a monologue that worked really well I'm
just sorry to go back uh if someone's
singing even if there's no music and
it's just the actor singing and the
actor sag and everything's taken care
with the paperwork but they don't own
the rights to that song and it's not
under fair use or something so happy
birthday used to be the thing that
tripped everybody up but now it's not
now happy birthday is back to being
public domain so you go ahead and use
happy birthday as much as you want but
you used to see in older films because
people didn't want to pay for happy
birthday that their birthday song that
they would sing when people would pull
something in was not H our traditional
happy birthday but some madeup song that
nobody in the right mind sings but it is
you know they made it up and it's a
brand new song so there you go um so
yeah you don't want people actively
singing a song that already exists even
though it's not the actual recording you
have to get the sync license for that
song So wow and I would assume that's
much cheaper than the actual rights to
the music well I can go into a whole uh
thing about music but basically if you
license a song you have to get the syn
rights and the master license rights and
traditionally what they do is they U
make them the same so if you whatever
you pay the same think you would pay the
master so you know for example if you
and also you can get Festival licenses
for films that way too so that you're
only paying for rights to use that song
on the festival circuit and again you're
not making money off of it so you know
it's it's a smaller amount but um if
somebody later wants to use the film
commercially put it on a DVD not that
anyone does that anymore but put it on
TV or put it on airplanes then you have
to have the rights completely tied up so
music rights is a whole headache for
both short films and low budget
and what I always try to say is there's
so many composers out there who would be
thrilled to write their own song for you
and then you can um do the legal
paperwork properly and make agreements
and it should be done for you know
hopefully you can pay the composer a
little bit of money too but um it should
be much more inexpensive and it's a
great opportunity for everybody the
composer gets to write a song or compose
the music for your short film gets a
credit you get something that's unique
to your film everybody wins what do you
think 99% of filmmakers get wrong with
their short films well it's not fair to
say 99% of filmmakers get wrong because
there's no wrong or right in short films
and who am I to say what's right or
wrong that's the great thing nobody gets
to decide what is good for films so
there there is nothing but I will say
length is always the problem I hate talk
always harp about length but I think
what people get wrong is they do too
long of films or the film that they have
made a FIV minute film that is somehow
eight minutes but really should be cut
down being five
minutes and who is the one that sort of
decides that like I'm sure so filmmaker
stink well no I need this one scene in
here though yes I've helped critique
films the work in progress where I will
try to talk forever to convince them
that that scene is not necessary and the
filmmaker insist it is and it's you're
making that film you get to do whatever
you want to do so I can try to push you
this way or that way but it's your film
you should stick by with what you think
it is and maybe that scene means
everything to you and it really is the
whole reason you made the film and
that's why you want it in and I can talk
myself blue in the face trying to
convince you it isn't necessary we've
already done that point if we take it
out no one's going to going to miss it
um but ultimately you know that's where
you as the filmmaker get to be the final
arbitrator with a short film Nobody Else
is paying for it or making it a
commercial you know man quite often if
you're doing it in a school situation
sometimes you have to do what the
professor wants you to do but then you
can recut it on your own and make it
what you want it to be and use that one
as the film you show people it's your
piece you're making it it expresses you
you should do whatever you want to do
what makes people stop watching a short
film let's say one minute in so with
with anything short film or feature the
viewer gets to decide what they want you
know we only have so much time in our
lives so if you start watching it and a
minute in you have no interest in it and
you think it's terrible nobody's going
to put a gun to your head and say you
must keep on watching it if you're in a
festable situation you paid a ticket to
go see a program with short films you
are kind of stuck in the theater and you
have to you know watch the whole entire
piece as they go on but um you know the
viewer gets to decide whether they want
to keep on watching or not the unfair
part is and this is someone who has been
a screener for festivals or um has been
a screener for various contests because
shorts sometimes have a major change at
the end that switches everything out and
makes you think differently of
everything that happened at the
beginning sometimes it's weird or
incomprehensible or something's
happening at the beginning that you
don't understand yet because you haven't
put the time in to hear the rest of the
short and see how it switches at the end
so truthfully because we're going to
give you the benefit of the doubt people
should watch the short film to the ENT
iry because it really could have a twist
ending that makes it all um what you saw
previously now make complete
sense and also what we said earlier
about how you know sort of the cliches
of the alarm clock or or vomiting H
maybe we'll give a pass on the vomiting
I don't know but you know but we can
always make exceptions like how many
great shoms do start with the stupid
alarm clock you know so what we're going
to say they did the alarm clock shot
we're turning this off we're not going
to watch this you you have to forgive it
and there's also so many ways you can
tell film stories too you know so um I I
say this is a unique voice that has put
something out there special and unique
it hasn't had a million people put their
thumbs on it and and uh give you know
criticism or deband it has certain
things to be commercial so who's to say
what this is going to be or what it is
so I would never I would not recommend
judging a short film like one minute in
um again maybe it's horrible and cheap
and the sound is terrible but there's a
reason for that then we're going to pull
back and realize this is a film within a
film or something like
that can you make a short film for no
money you can totally make a short film
with no money in this new world of you
have an iPhone in your pocket but also
and I don't think the camera is the most
important thing whatsoever but you have
a phone in your pocket you can use also
I guarantee you you know somebody who
has a more expensive camera that they
are not using that weekend and will lend
it to you bartering is the best thing in
the world if you have editing skills you
know somebody who wants to make a film
FM say that I will gladly edit your film
for free if you come and shoot my film
when I'm ready to make my short film if
you uh you know bring your camera I will
then do your edit so barter your skills
with other people that's one of the
things we have to offer that we don't
need to be paid we really can um our
time has value and we can offer that our
skills have value um but if you wake up
film for no money you have to realize
the kind of film you can make in no with
no money you're not going to be able to
make something that is a knockof of a
big Studio film you know however if your
day job is doing special effects for a
big Studio film and you have access to
all that equipment and you can use it
for free on the weekend or whatever
maybe you can make something that's
crazy impressive um because you have
access to this equipment that other
people who had to pay have to pay you
hundreds per hour to get somebody to do
it wouldn't be able to do so then have
sort of a like-minded network of people
where you can switch off and do
different tasks for each other and and
be open to working on other people's
films too I can't tell you how many
filmmakers want to make a short film and
have never worked on anyone else's film
especially among students and it's like
go on somebody else's set help them out
and then learn what they're doing wrong
short are learning experience for
everybody see and then you say oh I'm
never going to do that or you know you
go on and work on a set and you realize
ah this is a big waste of time or they
had too many people I never forget I met
a filmmaker who uh made his film at
school he had 50 cast me 50 crew members
on his film and we were like 50 what is
that it's ridiculous he's like we were
at school everyone was willing to help
it's like well I would never use 50
people on my film um but you know in his
case it made sense for him and it worked
for him and he was happy with it so
who's to people have unique situations
that they have advantages and
disadvantages of so you should use the
things that you have advantages of if
you want to make something with no money
and if someone's not in film school
where can they sort of find other
filmmakers to just volunteer to get
their feet wet that's why I think if you
work on other people's films then you
meet people that way right so even if
you PA on film you're looking and
clocking around saying who's great at
this who can I you know be friendly with
and say hey by the way I'm going to be
making a short film soon would you be
willing to come and do that also there
is you know Craigslist or mandy.com
there's places to also uh you know like
UCL extension has a website where their
students can list that they're available
to work on Films there's film
organizations in Los Angeles and again I
keep on speaking about Los Angeles
because I'm from Los Angeles but I'm
sure in whatever City you're in there's
a Film Society or film organiz ation the
other big tip that I love is like if you
have a film festival in your city
volunteer to work at that film festival
because you're meeting other people who
love film and want to be involved in
film so not only might you meet people
who come into the film festival but
you'll meet other volunteers who I
guarantee you be happy to work on your
film because they too have the same
sensibility you have they want to be
making these films they love films so
that's like the number one tip that I
love is like work at a volunteer at a
film festival in your local Hometown or
Film Society and meet people who have
similar interest and get them to work on
your film how often do you hear of a
short film costing let's say $70
million well um animation Pixar makes
these short films I don't think they're
$70 million but they're done properly
through Pixar you know where nobody's
working for free on those um so I don't
know what the budgets are for those
Pixar shorts but they're not done for
five cents those are expensive short
films also when you see the films that
are nominated for Academy Award for best
live action it's very rarely us
filmmakers it's usually um filmmakers
from other countries because their
countries actually support their
filmmakers and give them money so they
can make high quality films that feel
like big old feature films that just
happen to be 12 minutes long also the
academy loves a short film that's long
but you know like a 25 minute long film
that feels super expensive and like a
feature film is totally and is big and
important and dramatic that's totally
Academy catnip and it's usually made by
a country a filmmaker in a country where
that country gives them money to make
the film so it might not be Millions but
it's well-funded and so it's very hard
for a little uh you know us-based film
where the government won't give you any
money where there's no grants there's no
basically you know you either
kickstarting to raise some money or you
have wealthy relatives who are willing
to give you money um or you're paying
for it yourself you know there's always
that rule for feature films like never
put your own money into it but I'm like
in shorts you're putting your own time
and your own money and even if it's not
your own money your own time if you
calculated how much time you're putting
into this that you could be spending
earning money for that hours it's like
that's thousands upon thousands of
dollars that you've
contributed and in some ways it might be
best to put your own money whether
you're paying from your waiting tables
job or whatever it is because you're
going to learn lessons faster and you
can control it you know I the phrase I
always use is you are the studio when
you're making a short film you are like
a studio and then you get to decide what
you want to green light and invest in
and you have to take it all the way from
commissioning the script to releasing
ing it out into the world so you know
some studios can get away with like they
don't have any money and they're going
to do it totally cheap but um you know
like there's a lot of famous actors that
make short films or uh like
screenwriters those people have money
and so you can't expect people to work
for free for it and people aren't
expecting the films that they make to be
shot on an iPhone you know super Cheapo
kind of thing when you see a famous
actor who's directed a short film those
are properly funded and again they got
money to burn I'm sure they put their
own money into it um and they don't do
it for you know two cents on the iPhone
and they shouldn't you know that's not
what people are expecting from them and
you know if somebody famous were to ask
me to work on their film for free I'd be
like no I mean I love I would obviously
love to work with you you're super
famous and it would help my career to be
working with you but you also have a ton
of money I'm meeting you at your malib
mansion and you're asking me and my
little Toyota to come and work for you
for free no that's actually a film idea
there you go we're making film ideas all
the time yeah you're pulling up to the
gates the car stalls movie starts yes
yep yep yep great should a filmmaker
expect to make money from their short
film so the thing about short films is
there's really no money in short films
what you're investing in is you're
launching yourself as a filmmaker and
that film will hopefully get you other
will launch you as a filmmaker and
hopefully get you other work so you need
to think of it as an investment in
yourself and that's where the calling
card kind of aspect happens that like
I've created this to show you this is
what my talent is and therefore
hopefully you will hire me and pay me
money to move on to do the next thing so
even though they didn't give you cash
like here's $20 million for your short
film um they actually gave you $20
million to write a feature or something
of that sort um you uh so you can make
money that way it's it's by launching
yourself but actual shorts themselves
sometimes do make money there are still
a few places that will pay for um
license a short film the problem is so
it used to be called um interstitial uh
programming where movie channels like
used to have a feature that run short
and they need to put something else on
before the hour starts up again and
that's the short films I made for Fox
were for cable channel that used them
that way you had 20 minutes you had to
pad and so let's put some short films in
there and that way we padded the time
HBO used to pay money for short films to
use it in that way but now people all
they do is they do they'd rather make a
little featurette about a TV show to
convince you to watch that TV show and
fill up the time that way so
domestically there there isn't a market
so much for it anymore but PBS still
occasionally pays for short films the
apbs and when I say pay for they're
licensing it they're licensing your
short film to air in a certain way in a
certain market for a certain time um
they're not buying it out right there
are some markets foreign that also still
pay for films sometimes to be used on TV
intitially sometimes to be used in other
ways airlin
sometimes short films you know it used
to be too like oh my short film's going
to be on iTunes or Amazon and people are
going to pay me for that um and there
some are sorry the Academy Award shorts
by the way are their own category that
those actually get put in movie theaters
and people pay money to see the Academy
Award nominated short films which makes
me so happy sorry which makes me so
happy and that's for features and they
put the the animated shorts out that way
they put the feature the the liveaction
shorts out that way and and the
documentary and people pay money to see
them theater it's like it proves people
are interested they want to see these
films that the academy has said are
worthy and of value um and those films
do make money for the filmmakers uh so
there are C like weird ways that
sometimes films do make money and make
their money back um but oh that's a
unicorn you know most times you just got
to go in the understanding of sorry the
other way you can earn money is a
festival sometimes there's money prizes
at festivals so I know many filmmakers
who have made won more as Festival
prizes than they actually put into
making their film so they made a profit
that way from their Festival prizes so
um you know another reason to do
festivals is there is a category for
short films and you can be a prize
winner that way um so sometimes there
there are ways to make money the funny
thing too is like later on if you become
famous I you know we're very interested
in famous people's short films so they
might be interested in your film that
way once you become famous or maybe
really luck out and somebody starring in
your film it becomes famous later on and
then there's interested in so but would
stop you from making money on your short
film is if you didn't do everything
right if you didn't get all the cast
sign release forms giving you the rights
to their performances if you didn't do
deal memos so that some they're afraid
that some crew member will come back and
sue you when all of a sudden you're
making money if you have music in it or
not even music but artwork or clips of
other films that you don't have the
rights to that at the time you're like
ah what the Cal it serves my artistic
vision and it makes it great um but
somebody's saying hey I can give you
money but you have to have all these
things cleared you have to buy errors in
admission insurance which stops people
from suing you doesn't stop people from
suing you protects people when they're
being sued and you that costs money too
so there's a lot of sometimes and then
there's sag payments that change when
you actually sell your film so there's
sometimes uh there's other reasons why
you can't sell your film even if
somebody were to offer you the money for
the film but sometimes it's also
laughable it's like hey somebody in
Poland wants to license your film for
$13 it's like is it worth everybody's
headache to do all that paperwork to get
your film license for
$13 and and is it also too let's say
like Brands like if you if you have the
same way for again if you were trying to
learn how to do it right for the feature
film you should do all that right for
the short film so that you don't have
issues but you know it's like if
somebody in your short film is drinking
Coca-Cola but they're not like a
murderer or something like that they're
just accidentally drinking Coca-Cola
nobody's going to stop your film being
distributed being like you didn't clear
the rights for Coca-Cola it's not that
big of a deal it would be more if you
know the Killer Clown kills everybody
with the Coca-Cola can then there could
be an issue that Coca-Cola would not
approve of that use of their can in that
way what if it's uh you have a scene
where there's like a couple at the table
and there's a replica of a Renoir in the
background right is that someone still
needs to clear the rights for that yeah
they do definitely um and that's always
kind of surprising thing I heard about
recently that I never even thought about
was tattoos that the tattoo artist has
created original artwork so if it's the
real tattoo you're using it in a very
obvious way in the film it isn't just
like they're walking and they happen to
have tattoos down their arms but there's
a big part of the film that focuses on
this tattoo you have to get that cleared
from the tattoo artist who created that
as original artwork wow is that that's
new and sort of a new new to me it was
explained to me and I was like I never
even thought about tattoos okay but that
is original artwork too well you can get
temporary ones exactly whoever designed
that temporary one you need to get them
to sign to say that they gave you
permission to use their artwork for wow
I know crazy isn't it wow that's
fascinating to know that again everybody
you know is creating something uh
artistically so you know what I always
say so documentary there's a lot more
lean way because they're curing real
life but for narrative filmmakers the
argument is you are creating a fictional
World in which you've touched everything
in that and decided everything's in
there for a reason so if you've chosen
to have this Renoir in the background
then there's a reason that you've done
that and then you should appropriately
pay everybody if not take the Renoir out
get a cleared artwork or just go in the
back and scribble it yourself and put
something else in there because you've
chosen all of that sure sure yeah just a
couple brush strokes and just pretend
it's some kind of modern art piece there
you go it's done and you know often
greeking is what they call it when you
put like tape over something so it looks
different or changes it out something or
uh you know we often say um because you
often have crew members be your uh cast
and be your extras or whatever you just
really want to watch their clothes
because often crew members are wearing
like a Panavision t-shirt shirt like
could you turn your t-shirt inside out
could you take oh um Major League
Baseball or any kind of Major League
major a sports thing they all want money
so you don't want somebody with a
Yankees cap or you don't want somebody
with an NFL branded Dodgers whatever you
know all that is protected you can't do
and U again I'm based in Los Angeles so
I will of course say Dodgers or whatever
but the Hollywood sign is also something
that's protected um and so you have to
pay for the used to use the Hollywood
sign and you can't just be like who's in
the background it's like we'll pick a
different shot so it's not in the
background but they want money they know
about it and they also actively screen
to look for it if you've used it and
they will come after
you once a filmmaker has finished their
short film what should they do so when
you finish your short film you have to
decide how do I want to what do I want
to do with this sometimes I honestly
think you're not going to show it to
anybody it's you know it was a learning
experience there's a lot that's not good
about it and don't show it to people but
often you've made it because you want to
show it to people there's a reason you
put all that time and effort into it now
you've decide what do you want to do
with it and they're basically two routes
one is the festival route because that
is the uh screening for short films and
in a making them Prof professional pro
professional things that people will see
through the Festival circuit and
launches you as a filmmaker and gives
you an on train to the professional film
making world so festivals is One World
and if you want to do that you know you
it costs money so you need to decide how
much money you want to put into that and
how much money you can do and you know
set of marketing budget frankly to do it
that way so festivals is definitely
legitimate like a lot of short films are
made for the festival circuit a lot of
films are just going to be put on
YouTube you know we made them digitally
I want to share them with the world and
it's funny because a lot of times people
think oh I don't want to have my film on
YouTube and then later they're like
10,000 people have seen my short film
there's no way unless you that you could
get 10,000 people to see it on the
festival circuit you know so if your
point is that you wanted to communicate
with people and have people see your
film how amazing is YouTube you doesn't
charge you or or Vimeo there's other
places there's actually a lot of places
you could put your film online but you
know how amazing is that that you can
get your film seen by people that way
and there's places like short of the
week where they want to you know put
your film out and you're put in an arena
where people are actively looking for
short films and seeing it that way so
there's a lot that you can do with your
short film online the negative thing
about putting your film online is that
if you want to later do festivals
festivals still don't like it if your
film's been online because they're like
why should our patrons pay money to see
your film when they could actually just
see it for free online same thing if by
some miracle uh your film could
potentially be Academy Award uh
qualification they do not want it to be
broadcast first before you're qualified
so people put their film online and then
they can't be considered for the Academy
Awards very few films actually you know
get nominated for an Academy Award or
considered for the Academy Award so I
wouldn't kill yourself about that and
but if you think your film is an Academy
Award kind of film especially animation
or doc think about that and be smart
about it um if that's the venue you want
to go um and then you know sometimes the
films can be put on TV and that's a
fabulous thing too um if if that's an
option or you know maybe they've been
made for commission by TV or whatever um
and but everything has to be done right
when you're going to put it on TV
obviously all the rights and etc etc
have to be done perfectly so you need to
think about where you see this film
going and what to do with it I'm sorry
you can also um and this is something I
love to do is have your own screening of
the film very easy to do it in your home
or even rent a theater it's surprisingly
easy to rent a theater or speak to your
like local Film Society and see if
they're willing to put the short in
front of a feature film that they're
showing you're a local they know you
hopefully you're a m of the Film Society
they want to encourage you quite often
those kind of screenings also don't
count as Festival screenings so that you
can do that and still do the festival
circuit and not have it count as like
your debut or anything like that so you
know figure out where you want to show
this and then try to get it done and and
um you know think outside the box as
they say it doesn't have to be Festival
doesn't have to be online think about
film festivals think about other places
that might potentially want to you know
show your film in some way um but don't
think that that isn't a big part of the
process if you've made this film to be
seen it's going to take a lot of time I
know filmmakers who've been very
successful in the short film circuit and
had to spend like two years following
their film on the festival circuit
submitting it making sure it got seen
occasionally getting to go to the
Festival Etc and then that becomes a
full-time job whereas they made that
film because they want to get hired to
do something else so sometimes you don't
see films after a little bit because the
filmmaker got what they wanted out of it
they don't want to keep on sending it on
the festival circuit it's like I've
already got an agent out of this I've
already got a job doing something else
what I don't need to spend more time in
the festival circuit so when films are
like big rock Starry kind of films that
way they win Awards and everyone's
interested in them the filmmaker is
often like I'm not interested so much in
doing that anymore because I got what I
I want out of it and so uh then
festivals will start offering incentives
too to make to make it worth your while
so if you look out and get something
that's really um you know that special
special film you can charge screening
fees you can uh you know they'll ask you
to be apply for the festival and they'll
wave the fees for submissions there's a
lot of things can happen if you get one
if you luck out and have one of those
films that everybody wants to show and I
know those fees vary but what what's the
typical short film entry fee so here's
the nice thing about short film
sometimes it's free sometimes it's free
for students is sometimes there's a
student fee sometimes there's a uh just
normal fee there's also always very
important a early fee a late fee and a I
guess standard fee whatever um so you
really want to look at that because that
can be a world of difference like if you
wait for the late fee and we're all tend
to be procrastinators and kind of be
like I'll wait until the very last
minute okay now I'm sending it in um
that could be the difference like a $100
for the late fee whereas if you sent the
early bird fee it was $25 or $35 so um
you know I would recommend don't be that
procrastinator and send it late only for
financial reasons also you can really
look on a film freeway and see well
where doesn't where's a free to submit
my film um and you know places that you
have relationships with like your local
Film Society shouldn't charge you you
know they should be willing to look at
it for free and so there's a lot of ways
you can do it for free without
submitting any money but Film Festival
submissions is expensive you know and it
is a joke that like my God I probably
spent more money on my Festival
submissions than I spent on my actual
film sure and you know and ask yourself
really what what do you want out of it
because sometimes it's just gratifying
to go there be part of the Q&A and and
show it with friends and then you feel
like you've accomplished something yeah
and who knows what will happen as a
result of that screening too you know
something else could happen you weren't
even thinking of and then that's great
and that's what you wanted out of it do
you often hear from filmmakers that
their goal is to make a viral video
viral is something that people used to
talk about a lot you know like oh it's
going to become a viral hit and um you
know even today if you're able to
something happens like that more power
to you but often it's there's no um
magic formula for that and it's also no
longer like if you build it they will
come that you can just put it up and all
of a sudden oh it becomes a viral video
some people can kind of plan on it a
little bit like oh uh I know a filmaker
who did this kind of runchy Father's son
story that he launched um but on
Father's day and did this whole kind of
press release about how it was going to
launch on Father's Day and so people who
are writing stories about you know what
to do watch to watch on Father's Day or
whatever could reference that so he
really thought it all out and had a hook
to make it of interest and did something
in that way but in general um I don't
think you
know viral thing is kind of a miracle
you know that there's some reason that
people start sharing it you know like it
gets on Reddit and a lot of people start
you know so some ways you control it and
some ways you can't control it um in the
old days they used to be like Star Wars
fan films that had this built-in fan
base that people love these Star Wars
things and there wasn't so much star
Star Wars um material being made so
people those kind of videos could go
viral but now there's so much Star Wars
stuff officially done that I doubt
you're going to get a viral Star Wars
video happening you know it's like
there's enough talk about the official
stuff going on um so I think it's
impossible to kind of like pre-program
something going viral you never know how
it could happen and if it happens more
power to you and you know ride that
storm as much as you can and be prepared
the one thing you can do is be prep
prepared for what happens next because
you know it's like so now something got
viral and people are talking to you and
they want to when people start talking
about to you because like your film did
well at the festival or did well online
or whatever they don't really care about
that actual short itself they're not
going to do anything with it you know
they're not looking at it to you know
put in the movies or something like that
they're looking at like you have talent
you put you've got their thumb on the
you know the pulse of excitement now I
want you to do that for me what can you
do for me so you need to be prepared
with I have a feature film that I want
to get made you know I have uh this uh
pilot for a TV show I'd like to shoot or
would you look at my pilot for my TV
show I want to get that made you have
something else that they can be involved
with that you know now that you have
heat you can capitalize on that heat and
but it's not your short that's going to
they're interested they're interested in
the talent that's shown in the short and
the attention that you have but they
want to know what's next and that's
where a lot of filmmakers make a huge
mistake is they don't have a what's next
their film does really well in the
festival circum people say oh my God
this could be a feature and you be like
talk to me in a year when I actually
write the feature it's like you want to
be I and I'm writing the feature I'm on
the finishing P touches of the feature
you want to be ready to go with that
thing that they can capitalize on and
you know the heat can turn into
something that can earn you money um and
move the the next step on your career do
you think some people though they think
this this won't happen they they this is
I'm just putting this out there and and
and I'm not going to get this attention
and that's why they don't properly plan
yeah or or you know it's such a big
boulder to push up the hill right you've
had to find it write this thing finances
thing get it up and put it in somewhere
and then deal with all the tsunami of
all the success you haven't had time to
write the feature film this whole thing
took you forever and you did it all
yourself you know so it wasn't like you
had a hundred things in your drawer that
you ready to do next it takes a lot of
work I know a lot of people who you know
that was it they did that short film and
then had all that hoo-ha and then now
what and then you're cold again and you
either have to make another film or uh I
also know people who just love making
shorts and so they're G to follow that
up with you know I'll have another short
next year and like every year they have
another short film and they send it out
and same thing everybody loves it and
somehow they can afford to do that and
uh they're profession quite often it's
animators um they're professional short
filmmakers who get to do whatever they
want you know and turn it into
that myth or truth you can't make money
by selling your short film
some people do make money so I don't
want to say and also it's not selling
it's licensing I always keep on having
to remind everybody that you're making
money by licensing your short film some
people do and and it's rare um but when
you hear about it and people make a ton
of money off of it we're like more power
to you good job so yeah it's rare but it
is possible myth or truth you can make a
short film with no money I say it's true
you can totally make a short film with
no money now when we say no money do we
really mean no money or do we mean like
no money but actually a couple hundred
dollars um but if you literally say I'm
not going to spend any money whatsoever
then I think it's the iPhone filmm that
you're using your iPhone you're doing
everything yourself uh you're not using
professional actors that you're paying
you're doing it with your friends and
then the post production you either have
really good friends that will help you
out or there isn't much post- production
on it and hopefully you're giving them a
good lunch or something afterwards so
there is money involved right well
that's the thing it's like well even if
you say I'm not paying anyone but I'm
buying their lunch then you know five
people people's lunch even if you're you
know being extremely cheap and doing it
for $10 which in inflation today you
can't do but let's say even 20 there's
100 bucks right
there for one meal for five people
including actors and director myth or
truth Executives and producers do not
watch short
films what no that's that is a myth they
do watch her films they might not watch
the film to the entire ending but they
they do want Holly the quote I loved
that an executive or an agent said that
I put in my book um was that uh
Hollywood is in love with Talent new
Talent so they this is where people
become show their Wares is in short
films H so no they love short films
because there's new Talent there are new
voices and you actually can see it so
you know a lot of people uh have
problems getting their script seen you
know we have no connections nobody's
willing to see my short my script they
won't it won't take on solicited
material but they will watch a short
film because the short film already
exists so you can't say that you know we
actually had another project it was
development that was similar to it it it
is there it exists and people are more
willing to look at it because you know
it's not as hazy as a script that could
be changed or we have something else in
development with it so short film's
going to open a lot of doors for you
because people are willing to see short
films where they're not necessarily
willing to look at a script myth or
truth a short film won't help you get a
feature made so much not true people
short there are many examples of feature
films that got made that were developed
off the short film or that the filmmaker
was hired because they made a short film
so and and doesn't happen all the time
but every year there's examples of
filmmakers who just made a short and
then got to make a feature so no short
films are fabulous launching pad to make
feature films and television myth or
truth short films are a waste of
time no number one short films waste
very little time because they're
short they're not they're never a waste
of of
time as a filmmaker you learn something
every time you do it as a viewer you
have a chance to maybe see something
you've never seen before so I love short
films I'm the biggest proponent of short
films I never think they're a waste of
time myth or truth a short film will
never get you a Hollywood job not that's
another one that's not true so many
examples of people who have gotten uh
use the short film to get the job just
recently there was example of Belair
that he had made a it was kind of like a
trailer short film or whatever and then
they got to make a uh television series
off of it um they're feature films all
the time that were developed off of a
short film so myth or truth every short
film gets a million
views oh I wish that were
true no there's very few short films
that get a million views uh and those
tend to get more than a million
obviously if you're in that category it
becomes something that a lot of people
want to see and you'd be surprised how
many you can have seen but um sadly so
many people put their film up and there
you know just everyone you know watches
it and that's it why is the myth of a
million viewers
unlikely it's no longer the ER of if you
put it up they will come that someone's
just going to stumble upon your film and
see it that way there has to be a reason
that they've searched it out and want to
see it so um you know even with a lot of
promotion there it's the same problem
that everybody has TV shows have it big
old expensive Hollywood features have it
people only have so much time and so
when they have so much time what are
they going to actually watch uh I was
just some I think it was one of your
pieces where he was complaining that
people would rather play fortnite than
watch a film so you know it's like
you're competing with all these
different I myself see it I will spend
all this time going on Instagram you
know and it's like that's time I could
have watched three short films but
instead I'm flipping through people's
stories on Instagram um there's just so
many other things that take people's
attention and also I mean here I am I'm
the biggest promoter of short films but
i' I know a lot people have seen short
films that they just thought were
terrible or were dull or were long as
soon as people don't have great
experiences watching short films it's
really hard to convince them that they
want to see a short film um so you
know very limited attention span um
where you think like a it's only two
minutes can't you please watch it just
to get somebody to watch those two
minutes is very hard you know I kind of
a short Change short TV actually um
short TV shows films short films on TV
they have their own channel uh they do
license films and try to license films
Beyond it too there are definitely ways
that people who' have invested in short
films and want people to see short films
and put them out there and the Academy
Award short films that go out on the
festival on the theat theatrical circuit
where you can see it in your own
Hometown in the Arts Theater um so there
are lots of ways that short films do get
seen and great short films get seen I
think quite often it is that curated
thing of somebody saying wouldn't You'
like to see the short film that won
Sundance versus hey my brother shot
something on his iPhone which one would
you like to see now sometimes that thing
on the iPhone is fabulous and the short
film that one at Sundance is painful but
um you know in general the there there
is that curation thing of I think a lot
of people would rather see the Academy
Award nomination short the Sundance
award winning short or some viral thing
that people said this is amazing you
totally have to watch it and then you
watch it myth or truth 99% of short
films are
awful so um I don't think so I think
there's a lot of great short films but
you know suance releases the numbers of
films that are submitted to the festival
each year and so last year in a pandemic
year over 10,000 shorts were programmed
how many did they show of course it's
limited by how many they can actually
show but they showed like 59 short films
so you know if all 10,000 of those were
amazing wouldn't that be just like oh my
God how can we not show all 10,000 of
them but no obviously what's that number
that's close to 99 of them only um you
know 59 of them are going to be and
again there I'm sure there were a lot
like 150 of those other ones that would
should have been programmed but they
just couldn't have been but I'm sure of
those 10,000 5,000 of them were just you
know drek myth or truth these days fan
films are better than Hollywood
movies well you know Hollywood movies a
lot of people like to go see Hollywood
movies so we're not going to Discount
that whatsoever and when we say fan
films we're saying that films that are
kind of like take some existing property
um and use that in some way to make
something of their own um and there is a
passion you know why people would be
interested in it is because they're
interested in that topic um so like for
example there used to be a lot of Star
Wars fan films that people would make
but um now people's stes are so all over
the place it's hard to know what a fan
film people might be interested in but
actually I'll go back to the belir
example again that that was a fan film
that he liked the original fresh prints
and he thought of a unique way of doing
it and made his own version of the fresh
prins um that was a different take of it
and made a little short film and then
people were interested in that and as a
result of that they made it into a TV
series if it had not been with that hook
a hook of this is my reimagination of
the French Prince Belair people wouldn't
have been as interested in it when you
say that he did a variation or a
different spin on it what what was that
he took it and made it dark as if you
know you know because the original
concept for fresh princi was he got in
trouble back in Philadelphia and had to
come out to B air so this made him
really get into trouble and it turned it
very gritty and uh made it not a happy
go-lucky sitcom but a a dark you know
current day take on the idea of somebody
who got in trouble and had to come out
to uh
California what is a lowbudget movie
lowbudget movie it's so hard to Define
what a lowbudget movie is because
sometimes you see something that was
made and it's like $10 million and that
is way low budget for Hollywood but is
that low budget like you and I could
afford to make a $10 million film
feature film I don't think so but it is
considered low budget so Kota that won
the Academy Award this year is a
lowbudget film that was made for $10
million but that was obviously a
financed film it wasn't out of her own
pocket that she made that film um there
are people who can make films out of
their own pocket many years ago but it's
still a prime example is Robert
Rodriguez um El Mariachi that he made
for $7,000 that he earned the money by
selling his body to science very famous
story you know he's written an entire
book about it but he made an entire
feature film shot on film uh for
$7,000 I I know L of people have made
feature films for like 10 11,000 five
$15,000 but that's not shooting for a
long time that's shooting for a very
limited time in very limited locations
um and it's not going to compete with a
Hollywood film whatsoever it's going to
feel very much um you know like there
isn't a lot of money there and hopefully
there's some kind of story that just has
to be told and the filmmaker couldn't
wait around to try to get real funding
for it so they just made it themselves
you know they like by hook or break
crook this is getting made with whatever
money I can can raise hopeful Maybe by
you know Kickstarter or something like
that uh but whatever money I can make
for us we're going to make this film and
that's what I consider like a it's not
low budget at that point it's no budget
that's always the term you use it's like
no budget film um but there are levels
there's you know and sag has different
agreements for how much money you know
there's a ultra low budget low budget no
micro budget Etc there are um official
terms for like what money categories are
but I think um most filmmakers if
they're doing it themselves are doing it
on the no budget School how is a $1
million movie a lowbudget
film well I know $1 million sounds like
a lot of money but it isn't $1 million
is you know can goes away in a second
and that that remember that one million
is not just C covering production it's
post- production as well um so you know
and if you're using paying for locations
and paying for people and you have to
pay for people when you're making a
feature film even if you're shooting it
as quick as you know um 11 days or 18
days days paying for people paying for
locations paying for
food eats up a lot of money so um you
know I don't have a million dollars so
I'm not making a million dollar film um
I know a lot of filmmakers that took a
long time to be able to raise that kind
of money um but when they were able to
raise that money they made films that
did get attention you know usually on
the festival circuit trying to but It's
Tricky on the festival circuit now too
it's very hard to get the vesal circuit
to program a film that it has to be
really exceptional that has no star in
it that was made for no money uh you
know we live in the world unfortunately
now where there's too much content so um
you know you have to have a reason why
people should watch your million-dollar
film and hopefully the reason is you're
a very unique Storyteller but I tell
people this all the time we're kind of
waiting for the next Quin Quinton
Tarantino to arrive there hasn't been
anybody for a long time that just
radically blew everybody away for film
that they made with nobody no money and
no stars but they had such a unique
voice so you know that's what we're look
we're looking for that really unique
person that comes through has something
super interesting to say and is telling
it in a very unique way and blows us all
away with what they want to do and quite
often what it is is people are just
doing Hollywood movies or Hollywood TV
shows cheap and that's what they want to
you know they funded it themselves and
they can totally do it but it's not
special or unique or worth our while
watching well you know I I know you're
an Elvis fan and you've written a book
about Elvis so if we took the same
analogy uh for for we're waiting for the
next Elvis right I mean there's so many
quote unquote Elvises now I think it's
harder to sift through completely soiled
that's it takes a lot of money to launch
somebody to make them you know so Billy
Alish who my niece adors it's like that
took a she was self-produced and all
this kind of stuff but it took a lot of
money to launch her so the fact that
she's doing Arena tours and things of
that sort it's not a cheap cheap thing
to um to become internationally known so
it's there's just too much content now
what are three keys to making a
lowbudget
film uh well it's what you can achieve
in with that money um I just like with
short filming I don't think you should
be so ambitious that you have to do like
a really low rent version of what you
can do I think you should make something
spectacular with the money that you have
so you want to look carefully at what
you can do with that money also it's a
big commitment I often and I'm coming
from someone who loves shorts I would
recommend you do a killer short for is a
weak Feature lowbudget Feature people
it's hard enough to convince them to
watch your fabulous eight minute short
to convince them to watch your 90minut
feature is asking a lot it has to be
really special and unique uh and when
those show up people are super excited
about but I ask you you tell me how many
one well you've seen them on TV but you
know how many $1 million films have you
paid money to go see in the
theater um well I don't know if they
were one million they might have been a
little more but I I do appreciate you
know art housee Cinema I know I'm not
supposed to say that word I'm sorry I do
I say
too but you
know you're right I I I'm actually more
geared toward a lowbudget film than I am
some big Hollywood tent pole the the
amazing because I teach low budget film
making um the amazing thing last year
the films that got nominated for the
Academy Award because it was the
pandemic year and because they didn't
Hollywood didn't want to put their
expensive films out in the theater they
were amazingly lowbudget the films that
were all nominated I mean Nomad land
things that kind of films they weren't
$1 million doll films but minari I think
was very close to a million dollars so
there were a lot it was a nice category
last year that there were a lot of films
that were made for very little money um
drive my car this year I think was made
not an American Film but you know made
for very little money too so there there
is amazing sometimes when these $1
million doll films can go as high as
being Academy nominated and you're like
oh look what they did with a million
dollars truly impressive what are some
strategies that anyone can use to break
down a screenplay and analyze a budget
locations is a big part because you know
if you're going to be moving a lot of
locations that takes a lot of time so
quite often you'll see for low budget
films they're set in a few locations and
they don't move that much plus you have
to actually secure those locations so
that's why you see a lot of lowbudget
films that are shot in somebody's home
because you can shoot in your own home
you know you don't have to move around
you can shoot in different parts of your
home and get a lot of production that
way you see a lot of them shut in cars
same thing it's very easy to be driving
and filming and it looks nice and
there's motion and things like that um
so you got to think about how many
locations there are how many actors
there are um how long it's going to take
you to actually shoot it those are the
kind of three big things that kind of
delve and how expensive it's going to be
and how many films can you think of that
were successful in one location I mean
you can think of tape that that was
excellent you know but you'd be
surprised how many things are kind of
set in the house that you didn't even
think about it that it was set in the
house it's a great film called the
invitation um Karen kusama's film that
was like you know it's kind of a horror
or ther kind of film and they're all
brought to be at the house um that's
kind of a traditional um you know
everyone gets murdered in the house kind
of film type of thing um and there's a
lot of films you haven't seen that are
truly just talking people in a
house what tips do you have for
maximizing onscreen value so you know
everything the money should really be
spent so it looks great on screen uh one
of the things that I always tell my
students uh when I teach low budget
filmm is white walls are a big Bugaboo
that they look um they look cheap White
Walls totally look cheap uh and it makes
everything look terrible so as much as
like I can shoot for free in my kitchen
well if all those cabinets are white and
it just it'll look incredibly cheap
where it's so easy to hang a backdrop or
put some you know make some artwork or
whatever and have that in the backdrop
the camera loves detail the camera loves
a lot of things uh to look very full so
uh there are tricks you know to make
things look more expensive than they are
um and also so think about what you have
access to that is more expensive than
you would that somebody else would have
to pay for so you know if you want like
if the character has to have an
expensive car but you don't actually
have an expensive car who do you know
who has an expensive car who would lend
it to you for the day you'd be surprised
how many people you know who have things
that contribute to the production value
and when you say artwork you say make
artwork that is a key right there
anything that's copyrighted you have to
be very careful about what what you're
doing and and someone think like oh well
let's shoot a scene in the bus well if
you don't have the rights to shoot in
the bus and later on especially for a
feature film feature film your dream is
a feature film is going to get
distributed in some way so everything
has to be cleared in the feature film
and you can't do as many risky things as
you can with a short because short
nobody's cares nobody's gonna make money
we can do whatever you want to do more
or less but for a feature the the dream
is to have this re released into the
public so you are in control of
everything in a narrative film you need
to make sure that everything is cleared
and everything is done properly and you
have leases and all that kind of stuff
there's no excuse to be like oh well we
were friends so I didn't have him sign
anything and then later on the whole
chain of title falls apart because you
didn't have all you didn't have your
script copyright you didn't do this you
didn't do that um and then your film
becomes problematic how would you budget
a $5,000 movie can you give us a
breakdown so don't think of it all as
the production part because post-
production counts so much so I would
definitely think about what kind of
access do you have for stuff in
postproduction and then what kind of
post-production are you going to need to
spend money on because what people often
do is they just blow it all on
production it used to be called getting
it into the can when it was actual film
R reels that would be put into the can
then you have to worry about developing
it and all that kind of stuff we still
use that term in the can of like okay
you finished shooting but now what do
you do and they've often just stole all
the money had for post production
because you desperately needed it for
production just start spending it
because you needed to and all of a
sudden it's like and now there's post
and there's no money in it so I would
definitely recommend of that money post
production is so important and adds so
much and you can get so many things for
free in production that you can't get in
post so I would definitely I would say
even if you want to cut that money in
half and put half for production and
half for post knowing again you're
probably going to steal some of that
money from post when you get in trouble
in production because it's just sitting
there and you always think I can earn
more money later on um but so I I would
truthfully split in half and be like
okay half of that's going to be for
production uh post production and if
you're going to send this off just with
a like with the short if you're GNA send
it off on the festival circuit you
should have some marketing money set
aside too so make make that combination
post SL marketing money and spend only
25 on production and then you have to
think of like okay well how many days
are we going to shoot because if we just
ballpark it if you say like even if I
spent no money in pre-production and
just did in production well if I'm
shooting you know 25 days well now I
only have $1,000 dollar a day and what
that starts dividing up into this and
that and that it's like well that's no
money so mostly short mostly low
production films shoot less days because
then you can have more money per day but
for $50,000 film depending on what your
situation is I would think you're
shooting maybe 12 days as opposed to 18
days and and let's suppose you say well
judging the film probably won't get into
any major festivals it's a short so I
just want to go to local ones with my
friends so how much would you say
theoretically to put aside for festival
budget well so actually for short films
we alten really recommend doing local
produ local festivals because that's you
know where you know people and you can
have your film seen by people who know
you and you can go to the Festival
because you're there um but you still
want to try to submit it to other places
so there's application fees and then
there's travel fees when you do it so I
often kind of say to filmmakers well
let's say you know let's say you're
going to try just as a bad average but
like 30 festivals you might apply to and
average out $30 per application for a
short film feature films are more
expensive for festivals um and you know
some are going to cost more some are
going to cost less some might uh but
that gives you kind of like a ballpark
of how much you might spend and then you
want to budget at least a thousand or
two to go somewhere at some point if you
wanted to um but if you're local then
that's even better uh and you know
hopefully you won't spend that much
money at all is there any way to get a
big name actor for a $50,000 budget so
here's the thing about bigname actors
for both a short and for a feature
everybody always wants to work and you
know especially if you're a sag shoot so
they can work if they're a sag actor
they um in theory your project you were
so special and your project is so
special and they can get on the ground
floor of getting to do something that's
unique so I used to work for a casting
director many years ago and he'd say
about certain actors like they're great
cop number two well cop number two you
recognize that face because they've been
a great cop number two for whatever but
they want to be not necessarily cop
number one but they want to be the
Romantic lead or whatever and so here's
an opportunity for them to be the not
cop number one cup number two they get
to be the the Romantic lead and so they
will want to do your short or your
feature if you can have access to them
them the problem is they are also though
used to being on this TV show where
they've had the trailer and the hours
are such and the food is
such I always make the joke of like
they're not so good about changing
clothes in the Burger King
restroom whereas you know your friend
from film school is totally up for
that these people have are used to a
certain level of professionalism that
they might not be at the same level that
you are so that's something to think
about you know is this something it's
always should be everyone should be
making the same film and the person who
is you know used to TV money is not the
same person who's happy to change in the
Burger King restroom um so that's one
thing to consider also do you have
access to these people you know um but
you know maybe you're in an acting class
with somebody who is an actor of note
and you do have access to them and they
know you and you know they like to do
all these different things why wouldn't
you want to have this actor who's really
talented versus somebody who you know
you've never heard of and have no idea
how good of an actor they are um and
there's talk talk about hook or interest
a festival is more likely wanting to
let's just say Nicole Kidman was your
aunt Festival is more likely to play a
short film with your Aunt Nicole Kidman
in it um you're pretty much in as long
as the film doesn't suck and if you can
guarantee Nicole will come you're in um
so there's a big advantage of that but
then I always say then it becomes the
Nicole Kidman short and it's all about
Nicole Kidman being there and everyone
wants to talk to Nicole Kidman and if
you made this because it wants it should
be the you show all of a sudden it's not
the ow
so that's something to think about too
you know is your film any good or is it
all just because she's in it and that's
all people want to know about but
Hollywood would love to see that Nicole
Kidman shirt festivals would love to
play it you put it online and people
would be interested in seeing it you're
trading on that name sure and sometimes
they don't want to see the you show
until they know kind of who you've
worked with yeah oh yeah so more
inclined to be like uh she can work with
NI Cole Kidman I think she can direct
you know our little uh cup show or
something like that right where are
filmmakers most likely to
overspend shorts are a learning
experience for everybody so you don't
know what to spend on and what not to
spend on um so sometimes you don't have
the right access you know or somebody
says they really the cameraman insists
that they really need you to rent this
one of our short films the cameraman was
a commercial director and he wanted this
jib arm um and we're like we're not
paying for a jib arm and he's like I'll
call in favors so we didn't pay for it
but he called in favors but then we had
to wait for the jib arm to arrive and
the jib arm had somebody that carried
the jib and put it all together and
operated it so there was another person
on the set and all of a sudden this jib
arm that we didn't want but he wanted
you know cost us time you know versus
money so that things to think about of
all these decisions now it made the film
look fabulous and when you see it I
think it was probably worth the time and
money and I didn't pay for it so um you
know in that sense it was really
worthwhile uh we did a lot of short
films with with animals and we paid for
the professional animals um we didn't
know at the time that it worked that you
had to pay from the moment they left
their Ranch to the time they go back to
their Ranch so all of a sudden it was
extremely expensive to have these
professional animals and then one of the
little things that we did my famous
quote from that was we had a short film
that had a horse and a Frog and I'm like
why is the Frog more expensive than the
horse and the answer was it's harder to
train a frog than a horse totally
legitimate I completely understand now
yes that is the right answer and now I
understand and yeah we probably might
have had a friend who knew someone who
had a horse that could bring in the
horse or whatever but we probably didn't
have a friend that had a frog that could
do what we needed to do on camera on
time for a two-day short so yes it was
worthwhile spending money on that uh
frog so you know you could write a short
film starring a frog you think how hard
could it be for me to go I have frogs in
my backyard you know and then you
realize oh my God it is really hard to
make a film starring a frog and uh um so
even with the professional dog it took
longer than we thought it was going to
take that's really interesting I did not
know that hey you could have used Kermit
you could have exactly that's the way to
do it think something different okay so
now we can't afford a professional frog
so how cute would it be not Kermit
because that's copyrighted but uh let's
make our own somebody you know is
probably a puppet person or a craft
person who could put together a unique
frog for you and that might be a
different kind of film but I think that
would be a more interesting for a film
to have this puppet frog in it and then
also because this is unique property
maybe you've now created a character
that people are super interested in with
this frog and all of a sudden you get
meetings with people who are wanting to
do puppet shows and you have a puppet in
yours so now all of a sudden you're
getting hired to work for Sesame Street
because you couldn't afford the the
professional animal frog so it worked
out well and it made it different and
unique and yeah what's the best way for
filmmakers to keep their budgets down
save money so Robert Rodriguez was one
of the famous lowbudget filmmakers that
he made the film for $7,000 uh because
he sold his uh body to science to make
that kind of money and he has a terrific
uh making up piece called the 10-minute
film school that I actually show when I
teach because it's so inspiring it's on
YouTube you can easily watch it
but he says the secret to not pay money
is to to not let money go out of hand is
just to refuse to spend money and he has
an example from El Mariachi that they
had two different guitar cases one of
which didn't have um the the fabric on
the top and he's the quote he always
says is I was too cheap to spend a
dollar for a spray can to paint the back
of it so they had to do all this
complicated shooting to get around it
but that was he saved that money for the
spray paint so I'm the style producer
like it's only a dollar go buy the damn
campign to Let's spray and move on but
his you know every Comm every penny
counted for him and he sold his body for
science for every dollar for that so
just his tip was just refuse to spend
money you find a creative way to shoot
around your problems and don't spend
money and if you're like me like ah I'll
spend a dollar out of my pocket all of a
sudden it's like oh we don't have money
money for lunch okay here let me spend
more money for lunch and all of a sudden
you're credit card bill you leave the
film with why is my credit card bill
$122,000 it's because you kept on
spending stuff that you had to buy so
then you should keep an itemized list so
that you really see it in black and
white what you're spending well you
should make a budget and then you know
you can be harsh and say I'm not going
to spend more than this I'm a big fan of
contingency though put some money for
contingency because things happen and
you know you can say we're not going to
spend money but then something happens
and where's the money for that so we
can't control film making that's what's
kind of a miracle about it animators
animators can animators just sit there
and draw and they control abs everything
about it and the time is what takes time
or I'm saying old fashioned drawing I
mean they're doing on the computer right
they they it's all just computer stuffed
and then but there's still sound for
animation you still got to deal with
sound you still have to deal with music
etc etc um everything always costs money
and you can spend a lot of time getting
people to let you do it for free and a
lot of part of being a filmmaker is to
communicate and to talk to people and to
convince them that you're doing this
fabulous project and shouldn't they help
you and shouldn't they be along and it's
going to be a great experience and
nobody's getting paid oh my God the
whole film will come together if you
could just give me this free can of
paint or do you know anybody who has a
free can can of paint that they could
lend us you know you just have to ask
and put the time into it but that's
where it takes a lot of time uh you
know so you can list out this is what
we're going to need this is how much
we're going to paperhead etc etc but
then something always goes wrong sure
and we can also get caught up in the
spirit of it I think you you know
feeling good and feeling wow this is
going to be amazing let me just go over
this let me instead of going to this
fast food chain let me try this place on
ventur Boulevard that has this great
pizza and I want to really treat
everybody you know I mean that's not a
bad way to spend the money but but also
in the producer Wise It's like oh my God
it's going to take you 20 minutes to go
get that and pull it back and do that
and it's like H this is a bad decision
you know a better decision would be just
spend a little bit more money to bring
it here and do this and do that and
let's just and you're only making this
thing one the other thing I always tell
people too is when the film plays they
don't put a big sign in front of it it
says this film was only made for $50,000
nobody knows how much that film was made
for the thing that counts is what's on
the screen um so also another one of my
favorite quotes that I have in my book
that a filmmaker said was like nobody
ever walks away going um uh the acting
was terrible in that film but the props
were excellent we spent so much time
worrying about the props it's like the
acting is really everything we should
have really good acting it's so easy to
want it to be the house that looks
perfect and spends time getting the
lighting exactly right and and put that
prop right here whatever but people are
watching they forgive a lot they they
want a story well told uh via
storytelling and Via acting and the
supporting elements like sound Etc but
they have no idea how much you spent on
it and all they know is the final
product and the final product should be
something that you feel I mean you've
had to make a lot of artistic
compromises but it should be something
that you feel proud of and you're happy
to send out into the world and people
are thrilled to see and enjoy and film
is forever so this is something you're
sending out for the world forever and
that's how it
exists and so just as with let's say a
feature film there's the sort of taboo
about talking about the budget is there
the same taboo with short
films it's so flexible though because
like let's say I Bartered all this stuff
but then if I had to pay for it it would
be a different budget so something I can
make with my students with my
experiences and people I can call on for
favors is not something that you could
make if we had the exact same script I
could make it for a whole different
budget then you could make it for a
whole different budget and they'd be
different films obviously because it
would be my version versus your version
but it's not fair to compare because if
you're trying to do it for not paying
rate if we're paying rate for everything
then it should be exactly the same and
fair and equal but still my talent is
different than your talent you know and
I would pick different actors than you
would pick and if money was nothing look
how many films are made for tons of
money and they totally suck because
people didn't care about the story or
didn't have the they weren't filmmakers
and they weren't storytellers that's
what counts so you know budget SCH
mudget you know it's like again you're
making something that's permanent and
it's out there and it's being shared and
you're not going to get to remake it or
whatever um this is something that
exists and you should be happy with what
you did and you can also forgive
yourself for a lot saying it's a
learning experience and you know I
learned a lot from having made that and
a lot of people when they look back at
their early work cringe you know they're
like their short film sucked their
feature film sucked but I actually went
to an event for Christopher Nolan for
his first feature film following um
which got re-released and he was like
look I'm still talking about following
all these years later he's done all
these huge films I love following was so
fabulous and again people love that film
but he's like this still F still
following me around he still has to he's
still talking about yeah so you know but
but last but not least suppose you're
lucky enough to get into a festival
you're up there with a Q&A and then you
get the guy right question okay what was
your budget and you're like okay do I
tell him the truth so for feature films
the reason why you don't tell them the
truth is because there's a implied value
for it later on you know and you want if
if there's a bidding more for it and
they know you only paid a million for it
and they're not going to say and we're
giving you 25 million you know it's like
they're way over spending it that point
for what the value of the thing actually
is so you just don't tell them you know
it's like how much do you want to pay
for it what does it matter how much I
paid for it for a short film I think
it's just so many favors and all that
that what's the point of telling people
how much it costs I think people often
ask because they want to kind of figure
out C can they do it you know like if I
had if you made that for $1,000 then
maybe I could make it for
$1,000 um and if there isn't really a
market for it what does it hurt for you
to say a$ thousand but I think more
interesting is to say how how many days
you shot or something like that because
you can say okay I see what a 18-day
shoot looks like or I see what a two-day
shoot looks like and I see what a five
day shoot looks like and I guarantee you
if I showed you what a film that was
shot for five days and two days you
would totally see what you get
difference not just budget but you know
everything what the difference is so to
me it's more like days but so if
somebody ask a question you just you
just say oh my God we got so many things
for free and I'm and now you spin it
into your own way like the politicians
that don't want to answer and I want to
thank everybody here this theater's
filled with people who gave me things
for free and I want to take this
opportunity to thank you for your
contributions this film is not just all
about me this film is about all of us
and that's sincere too it's not just you
know politicians kissing
ass